Hello and welcome to your second drink of Michael Scott Paper Company.
We got a lot of fun details from our producer Randy Cordray for this one about Michael's car, Goldfish, Music Rights, and what it was like fitting everyone into that tiny office.
Yes.
This episode opens with Michael driving his car listening to music, and we got a fan mail flurry from Lee and Mallory M.
Tanya D. and Sarah W., who all had the same observation as Kirsten H. about Michael's
car. Here is what Kirsten said. Love this podcast so much. Being a new mama, staying at home,
this always helps me get through the day while doing chores around the house and not feel so lonely.
My question is this. Didn't Dunder Mifflin give Michael Scott his convertible PT cruiser for a company car?
你好，欢迎收看第二杯“迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司”。我们从制片人兰迪·科德雷那里得到了很多关于迈克尔的车、金鱼、音乐版权以及把所有人塞进那个狭小办公室的幕后趣事。是的。这一集以迈克尔开车听音乐开场，我们收到了来自李、马洛里·M、坦尼娅·D和莎拉·W的粉丝来信，她们和克里斯汀·H一样，都对迈克尔的车有同样的观察。克里斯汀是这样说的：非常喜欢这个播客。作为一个新手妈妈，在家带孩子，这总能帮我度过做家务的时光，让我不那么孤独。我的问题是：邓德·米夫林公司不是给了迈克尔·斯科特一辆PT漫步者敞篷车作为公司用车吗？
If so, how did he get to keep it after quitting?
That's a really good point. It is a good point. How did he? Did they just know this is a short-lived?
They're like, did they just, like, not have time to take it back yet?
I never thought about that.
That's such a great observation.
But, yeah, after giving us two weeks notice, you would think he'd have to return the company car.
Yeah, he would.
Maybe he purchased it from them.
如果是这样，他辞职后是怎么留住它的？这真是一个很好的观点。确实是个好观点。他是怎么做到的？他们当时知道这只是暂时的吗？他们是没时间收回吗？我从来没想过这个问题。这观察太棒了。但是，是的，在提前两周通知辞职后，你以为他必须归还公司用车。是的，他应该归还。也许他是从公司买下来的。
I don't know.
We'll never know.
We also got a fan mail flurry for the favorite scene of this episode, and there was a clear favorite.
Rebecca R., Sean C., Maddie S., Carly T., Simon C., and more, all said their favorite moment
in this episode is when Dwight and Andy are singing country roads to Aaron in the breakroom.
And you know, we love it too. We played it in our breakdown.
Yes, I love that moment. And you know something that occurred to me when I was revisiting this
我不知道。我们永远不会知道。我们永远不会知道。我们还收到了关于本集最喜爱场景的粉丝来信，有一个明显的赢家。丽贝卡·R、肖恩·C、麦迪·S、卡莉·T、西蒙·C等人，都说他们在本集中最喜欢的时刻是德怀特和安迪在休息室为艾琳唱《乡村路带我回家》的时候。你知道，我们也喜欢。我们在回顾中播放过它。是的，我喜欢那个时刻。你知道我在重温这一集时想到了什么吗？
episode and we did not talk about this in our breakdown was that this was Ellie's first week
of work. Michael Scott Paper Company is her first episode. I mean, what a way to jump in with this
serenade. That's bonkers for me to think about. I know. I mean, that's an amazing first week of work.
Well, we had to reach out to Ellie and ask her about this, and here's what she had to say.
She said, that banjo scene was insane for me. Yes, as a fan of the show, I was already living in a sort
of semi-conscious dream state, but then to have these two icons serenading me,
And then in parentheses, she said, my character, but let's be honest, really me.
Just kidding, just kidding.
我们在回顾中没有提到这一点，那就是这是艾莉工作的第一周。迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司是她参与的第一集。我的意思是，以这种小夜曲开场真是太棒了。想到这一点我觉得很疯狂。我知道。我的意思是，这是令人惊叹的第一周工作。好吧，我们联系了艾莉并询问了这件事，她是这样说的。她说，那段班卓琴场景对我来说太疯狂了。是的，作为该剧的粉丝，我当时已经处于一种半清醒的梦境状态，但随后这两位偶像为我唱小夜曲，然后她在括号里说，是我的角色，但老实说，其实是我。开个玩笑，开个玩笑。
But Ellie said it felt extremely surreal.
She said, I remember feeling that same sense of disbelief when Michael Scott and DeAngelo Vickers
were giving me conflicting instructions on how and whether to answer the phone at reception,
just all these giants of comedy.
Ellie said, anyway, at the time, I was only booked for four episodes, so I was especially
conscious of absorbing every moment. But also, I was in a semi-conscious dream state. It was a very
complicated experience of consciousness. Well, this was taking me back because my first one-on-one
scene with Ed Helms was him playing banjo. To me, to Pam, Rainbow Connection. Oh. So Ellie and I
但艾莉说这感觉极其超现实。她说，我记得当迈克尔·斯科特和迪安杰洛·维克斯就如何以及是否接听前台电话给我提供相互矛盾的指示时，我也感到了同样的难以置信，他们都是喜剧界的巨人。艾莉说，无论如何，当时我只签了四集，所以我特别注意吸收每一个瞬间。但同时，我也处于一种半清醒的梦境状态。这是一种非常复杂的意识体验。好吧，这让我想起了往事，因为我与艾德·赫尔姆斯的第一场对手戏是他弹奏班卓琴。对我，对帕姆，弹奏《彩虹连接》。哦。所以艾莉和我
both got banjo from Ed Helms, like, in our first week of working with him. I never got banjo.
I did get the sitar.
Yes.
And also I got, you know, broccoli rob and him singing acapella to me.
But getting Ed to sing to you in a scene is pretty amazing.
Well, also in this episode, I did a little mini deep dive on why pancakes like to be round
and why making square pancakes for this episode was a bit of a challenge.
I have to say that just the wording of that makes me laugh because it makes me feel like you've given pancakes a personality.
都在与他共事的第一周从艾德·赫尔姆斯那里得到了班卓琴表演。我从来没得到过班卓琴。我确实得到了西塔琴。是的，还有，你知道，西兰花罗伯和他对我唱的阿卡贝拉。但让艾德在场景中为你唱歌真是太棒了。另外在这一集中，我做了一个关于为什么煎饼喜欢圆形的迷你深度挖掘，以及为什么为这一集制作方形煎饼是一个挑战。我不得不说，光是这种措辞就让我发笑，因为它让我觉得你赋予了煎饼人格。
Why pancakes like to be round.
They like to be round.
But we got an interesting letter from Luke M who said that actually it's not just pancakes that like to be round, but all matter likes to be round.
So to further my deep dive, I thought I'd read what Luke had to say.
Luke said, hi, lady, my degree is in science, and I thought I could clarify why pancakes are round.
Matter likes to be at its lowest possible energy, and circles are the lowest energy shape.
That is why raindrops are circular, they're not actually teardrop shaped, and why you see circular
bubbles of oil on unmixed salad dressing. There's a lot of fairly complex chemistry that makes
为什么煎饼喜欢圆形的。它们喜欢圆形的。但我们收到了一封来自卢克·M的有趣信件，他说其实不仅仅是煎饼喜欢圆形，所有的物质都喜欢圆形。为了深入我的挖掘，我想读读卢克是怎么说的。卢克说，嗨，女士，我的学位是科学，我想我可以澄清为什么煎饼是圆的。物质喜欢处于最低可能的能量状态，而圆形是最低能量的形状。这就是为什么雨滴是圆形的，它们实际上不是泪滴状的，也是为什么你会看到未混合的沙拉酱上有圆形的油泡。有很多相当复杂的化学原理导致了
this the case, but it boils down to the fact that matter likes to be bonded to other things.
molecules on the edge have less things to bond to than matter in the middle where they are surrounded on all sides
and circles have the lowest surface area edge and highest volume middle so that's why it's matter's favorite shape to make
well isn't that just beautiful i love that yeah so every time you see a circle i guess you can just imagine
oh that matter is really happy it's matter's favorite way to be is a circle well finally we got this letter
from April C. April says, question for your next second drink episode. Who the hell is Toby talking to while he's peeing?
We don't know much about Toby's social life other than the fact that he doesn't seem to have one.
Talking to someone while you're in the bathroom is intimate to say the least. So who is Toby so comfortable with that he talks to them while he pees at work?
这一点，但归根结底是因为物质喜欢与其他事物结合。边缘的分子比中间被四面八方包围的物质有更少的东西可以结合，而圆形具有最小的表面积边缘和最大的体积中间，所以这就是为什么它是物质最喜欢的形状。嗯，这难道不美吗？我喜欢这个。是的，所以每次你看到一个圆圈，我想你可以想象，哦，那个物质真的很开心，它是物质最喜欢的存在方式。最后，我们收到了这封来自艾普尔·C的信。艾普尔说，给你们下一集“第二杯”的问题。托比在小便时到底在和谁说话？除了他似乎没有社交生活这一事实外，我们对托比的社交生活知之甚少。在洗手间时和人说话至少可以说是亲密的。那么托比和谁这么熟，以至于他在工作中小便时还在和他们说话？
And he's asking them for fashion advice? Who does Toby go to with these?
kinds of questions. Who is Toby's person? Does Toby have a person? Is this a partner, a sibling,
his mom? Theories, please. Oh my gosh. This letter makes me laugh so hard. So of course,
the scene April is talking about is down in Michael Scott Paper Company, Pam and Ryan and Michael
can all overhear the bathroom above that. The vent. And you hear the flush. And then they hear
Toby go into the bathroom and he's like on the phone with someone while he's peeing. Should we listen
to it? Yeah, yeah. It's a lot.
It's a little muffled, but let's hear it.
而且他还在向他们寻求时尚建议？托比会带着这些问题去找谁？谁是托比的“那个人”？托比有“那个人”吗？这是伴侣、兄弟姐妹还是他妈妈？请给出理论。天哪。这封信让我笑得太厉害了。当然，艾普尔提到的场景是在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，帕姆、瑞安和迈克尔都能听到上面的洗手间。通风口。你听到冲水声。然后他们听到托比走进洗手间，他在小便时和某人在电话里聊天。我们要听听吗？好的，好的。内容很多。有点闷，但让我们听听。
Not much.
What's up with you?
No, it's okay.
I'm in the bathroom.
Hey, you've been watching damages this year?
It's so good.
Now, you've got to tune in.
It's as good as anything on HBO.
没多少。你怎么样？不，没关系。我在洗手间。嘿，你今年一直在看《裂痕》吗？太棒了。现在，你一定要收看。它和HBO上的任何节目一样好。
Hey, just blue-go tan.
Somebody just make the copy?
Like a blue shirt.
I don't wear a lot of colors.
I have a lot of tan.
I mean, this is such a good point.
He didn't just go in there to make a phone call because you hear him peeing.
Yeah.
嘿，只是蓝色去晒黑。有人刚做过复印吗？像一件蓝色的衬衫。我不穿很多颜色。我有很多棕褐色。我的意思是，这是一个很好的观点。他不是为了打电话才进去的，因为你听到他在小便。是的。
Who is he talking to?
Lady, there are two people that I talk to when I'm peeing.
You and Lee.
That's it.
Not even my sister.
I talked to you.
Well, I talk to you.
I mean, I should say I'm not going in the bathroom, just having conversations.
他在和谁说话？女士，我小便时会和两个人说话。你和李。就是这样。甚至不是我姐姐。我跟你说话。好吧，我跟你说话。我的意思是，我应该说我不会走进洗手间，只是为了聊天。
Just happens sometimes, okay?
You and Josh, I will talk to while I'm peeing and Isabel.
Well, yeah, my kids in the house.
Yeah, yeah.
But I'm saying like.
Yeah. And I'll answer a phone call from you or Lee if I'm PA.
Yes. Yeah. Same. You and Josh and my friend Micah.
Mm-hmm. I mean, yeah, that's it.
有时就是会发生，好吗？你和乔什，我会在小便时说话，还有伊莎贝尔。好吧，是的，我的孩子们在家里。是的，是的。但我的意思是……是的。如果我在小便，我会接你或李的电话。是的。是的。一样。你和乔什，还有我的朋友迈卡。嗯。我的意思是，是的，就是这样。
So who is Toby's person that he's talking to? This is such a good point.
It really is. I mean, it feels very like family, right? It's a sibling or his mom.
I don't know. He's asking his mom about watching damages.
I know. That's the thing that threw me. I know. But it sounds sibling-like.
to me. Maybe. Wait, is it his brother? That's what it's got to be. Rory, his brother. Maybe so.
Played by Warren. Yes. Okay, I think that's what we're going to go with. That's what we're going
with. That is a really, really funny question, though. I loved it. All right, thank you all for
writing in with your questions and comments. We hope you enjoy your second drink of Michael Scott
那么托比在和谁说话？这真是一个很好的观点。确实如此。我的意思是，感觉很像家人，对吧？是兄弟姐妹或他妈妈。我不知道。他在问他妈妈关于看《裂痕》的事。我知道。这就是让我困惑的地方。我知道。但这听起来像兄弟姐妹。也许。等等，是他哥哥吗？一定是这样。罗里，他哥哥。也许吧。由沃伦扮演。是的。好吧，我想这就是我们要得出的结论。这就是我们要说的。不过，这是一个非常非常有趣的问题。我喜欢它。好了，谢谢大家写信提出你们的问题和评论。希望你们喜欢这第二杯“迈克尔·斯科特
Paper Company. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together.
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies.
Hello, everybody.
There is a new paper company in town.
Michael Scott Paper Company.
Holy moly.
造纸公司”。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。城里有一家新的造纸公司。迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。天哪。
We're going to talk about it today.
However, I have to say this before we get started.
What?
We look gorgeous today.
You all should know.
I don't know what this podcast is going to be today, but we...
look hot. Well, Jenna has that, like, dark, smoky eyeliner. I did a smoky eye today. How do you even
do that? I need a tutorial. Oh, multiple YouTube tutorials is how we got this smoky eye today.
我们今天要谈谈它。然而，在开始之前我必须说这个。什么？我们今天看起来太美了。你们都应该知道。我不知道今天的播客会是什么样，但我们……看起来很火辣。嗯，珍娜有那种深色的、烟熏的眼线。我今天化了烟熏妆。你甚至是怎么做到的？我需要一个教程。哦，多个YouTube教程就是我们今天化出这个烟熏妆的方法。
I did super straight hair. You look amazing. You look like you're about to take over, like,
multiple corporations. I am wearing a blazer. I know. I guess we have to say that because people can't
see us, but we look amazing. Angela, your nails look incredible. I mean,
details. We have details we look good, guys. We're filling it today. We cannot wait to talk about
this episode. And then we have a photo shoot. Jenna, who are we? What is happening? We're a big deal.
I don't know. Will you tell my kids that next time we're at Target? Hey, hey. Big deal over there in the
seasonal aisle. Yeah, and you can only pick one of those things. Pick one. You're not getting all three.
Let's get to talking about what we're here for. It's season five, episode 12.
我做了超直的头发。你看上去太棒了。你看上去就像要接管多家公司一样。我穿着西装外套。我知道。我想我们必须说出来，因为人们看不到我们，但我们看起来太棒了。安吉拉，你的指甲看起来不可思议。我的意思是，细节。我们有细节，我们看起来不错，伙计们。我们今天感觉很好。我们迫不及待地想谈谈这一集。然后我们有一个照片拍摄。珍娜，我们是谁？发生了什么？我们是大人物。我不知道。下次我们在塔吉特百货时，你能告诉我的孩子们吗？嘿，嘿。那边季节性过道的大人物。是的，你只能选其中一样。选一个。你不能全要。让我们开始谈谈我们来这里的原因。这是第五季第12集。
written by the amazing Justin Spitzer and directed by Gene Stubnitsky. He's the credited director on this one, but he actually had a partner. This episode was co-directed by Gene Stupnitsky and his longtime writing partner, Lee Eisenberg.
That's right. They would go on to direct many more episodes together of the office. They shared a little bit in the commentary that they would rotate who would take credit. It sort of went along some DGA rules at the time.
So Gene got credit for this one, but they were both there together every day, so we want to give Lee a shout out.
And then the next time there's an episode up that says Lee directed, know that Gene was right there by his side.
And we reached out to both of them, and they shared a ton of great details for this episode.
So I'm very, very excited.
Here is your summary.
Michael, Pam, and Ryan are in their new office.
由了不起的贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，吉恩·斯图普尼茨基导演。他是这一集的署名导演，但他实际上有一个搭档。这一集由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和他长期的写作搭档李·艾森伯格共同执导。没错。他们后来一起执导了更多集的《办公室》。他们在评论中分享了一点，他们会轮流署名。这在当时符合一些美国导演工会的规则。所以吉恩获得了这一集的署名，但他们每天都在一起，所以我们想向李致敬。下次如果有显示李执导的一集时，要知道吉恩就在他身边。我们联系了他们两人，他们为这一集分享了大量精彩的细节。所以我非常非常兴奋。这是你的摘要。迈克尔、帕姆和瑞安在他们的新办公室里。
They're struggling to adjust.
It's a very tiny, intimate work.
environment? Very tiny. Can I tell you one thing? Justin said they even considered finding a smaller
room. What? Can you imagine? I can't because I was there and I know how almost impossible it was to
shoot in that room. With like the camera operators, the sound department, you guys. Smaller room. That's
bonkers to me. Well, upstairs in Dundermifflin, there is a new receptionist in town. A new lady named
Kelly Aaron Hannon. Dwight and Andy are both kind of crushing on her, but they also have this new
friendship, so this crush is going to really challenge their new bond. In the meantime, Jim is trying to
他们正在努力适应。这是一个非常狭小、亲密的工作环境？非常狭小。我能告诉你一件事吗？贾斯汀说他们甚至考虑找一个更小的房间。什么？你能想象吗？我不能，因为我在那里，我知道在那个房间里拍摄几乎是不可能的。有摄像师、音响部门，你们。更小的房间。这对我来说太疯狂了。好吧，在邓德·米夫林楼上，城里有一位新的接待员。一位名叫凯莉·艾琳·汉农的新女士。德怀特和安迪都有点迷恋她，但他们也有了这种新的友谊，所以这种迷恋将真正挑战他们的新纽带。与此同时，吉姆正在试图
figure out, what the heck is a rundown? What is a rundown? Poor guy. And let's not forget
there's going to be some giant square pancakes. Yeah. Lady, I forgot that they were big squares.
I have details on that.
You do?
Oh, I can't wait.
All right.
I have some pancake details.
I can't wait.
弄清楚，到底什么是“简报”？什么是“简报”？可怜的家伙。别忘了还有巨大的方形煎饼。是的。女士，我忘了它们是大的正方形。我有关于那个的细节。你有吗？哦，我迫不及待了。好吧。我有一些煎饼的细节。我迫不及待了。
Let's get into some fast facts.
All right, here's a mini fast fact.
This episode actually aired the same night as Dream Team.
In between these two episodes, they ran the very first episode of Parks and Recreation.
How about that?
We were like a little singing lunch.
We were.
And we were the bread and Parks and Recreation was the...
让我们进入一些快速事实。好吧，这是一个迷你快速事实。这一集实际上和《梦之队》在同一晚播出。在这两集之间，他们播出了《公园与游憩》的第一集。怎么样？我们就像一顿唱歌的午餐。我们是。我们是面包，而《公园与游憩》是……
Baloney.
The cheese?
Cheese.
Sounds like a dig.
We don't mean it.
No, I didn't mean it to be.
I had a baloney sandwich every day in my lunch growing up.
No, but it's, you know, saying something as baloney or something as cheese.
博洛尼亚香肠。奶酪？奶酪。听起来像是在挖苦。我们不是那个意思。不，我不是那个意思。我从小午餐里每天都有博洛尼亚三明治。不，但是，你知道，说某事是博洛尼亚香肠或某事是奶酪。
It seems like a dig, but...
They were the meat.
Well, now that seems like a dig on the bread.
As if the bread isn't important.
Well, the bread's the best part.
That's just because I love bread.
Okay, we'll leave this analogy.
There you have it.
这看起来像是在挖苦，但是……他们是肉。好吧，现在这看起来像是在挖苦面包。好像面包不重要一样。好吧，面包是最好的部分。那只是因为我喜欢面包。好吧，我们离开这个类比。就是这样。
It was office, parks and rec office.
Yes.
Fast fact number one, I thought,
we should talk a little bit about this teeny tiny space of Michael Scott Paper Company, this 165
square foot office with no windows on the bottom floor of Dundermifflin.
With a exposed shower in the corner?
Yes, correct.
Now, that was a faky shower.
那是《办公室》、《公园与游憩》、《办公室》。是的。快速事实第一号，我想，我们应该谈谈迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司这个狭小的空间，这个位于邓德·米夫林底楼的165平方英尺、没有窗户的办公室。角落里还有一个暴露的淋浴间？是的，没错。那个，那是一个假淋浴间。
Oh.
That was a design by our set designer, Michael Gallenberg.
Because there was a real shower down there.
I had to use it one time, not in that room.
Across the hallway.
there was an office that had a tiny shower.
Really?
Yes.
哦。那是我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格设计的。因为楼下确实有一个真正的淋浴间。我用过一次，不是在那个房间里。在走廊对面。有一个办公室里有一个小淋浴间。真的吗？是的。
Why did you have to use it?
Okay.
Well, do you remember the summer my hair turned green?
Yep.
You could really see it on camera.
Guys, I spent the whole summer swimming with the kids in the pool and my hair turned green.
It happens to the blondies out there.
And Kim put this thing on my hair to like kind of tint it, you know?
你为什么必须用它？好吧。嗯，你还记得我头发变绿的那个夏天吗？是的。你在摄像机上真的能看出来。伙计们，我整个夏天都在和孩子们在游泳池里游泳，我的头发变绿了。这在金发女郎身上会发生。金把这个东西涂在我的头发上，想给它上色，你知道吗？
To get the green out?
To get the green out.
And I had to wash it out of my hair.
like you put it on and then I had to rinse it out and then she had to blow dry my hair.
Okay. Now, why didn't they just use the little sink in the hair and makeup trailer or the shower in
your trailer? Because the sink in the hair and makeup trailer, first of all, it didn't get hot.
And Kim was a little concerned because the water is like this sort of recycled water that it would
strip the color off my hair that she was trying to put in.
为了去掉绿色？为了去掉绿色。我必须把它从头发里洗掉。就像你涂上它，然后我必须把它冲洗掉，然后她必须吹干我的头发。好吧，那他们为什么不直接用发型和化妆拖车里的小水槽或你拖车里的淋浴间呢？因为发型和化妆拖车里的水槽，首先，它没有热水。而且金有点担心，因为水是那种循环水，它会洗掉她试图涂在我头发上的颜色。
Now that you say that, I know that because there have been times when I've needed to shower
off, your trailers have a shower, but it is exactly that. It's like a tank of weird sort of
chemically treated water. Right. So that it can stay in the tank and then not be poisonous.
Yeah. And it doesn't get very hot. And also, I've had people tell me not to use it. I sort of was like,
maybe just get rid of the showers and the trailers. Yeah, put in a closet. We all need a closet.
Always need more closet. I mean, it's part of my life mantra. Can I have more closets?
Well, you need closets for your baskets, ladies.
I do.
现在你这么说，我知道了，因为有时我需要冲洗掉，你的拖车里有淋浴间，但情况正是如此。它就像一个装满奇怪化学处理水的罐子。对。这样它就可以留在罐子里，而且不会有毒。是的。而且它不会变得很热。而且，我也有人告诉我不要用它。我当时想，也许只是把拖车里的淋浴间拆掉。是的，放进一个壁橱里。我们都需要一个壁橱。总是需要更多的壁橱。我的意思是，这是我人生格言的一部分。我能有更多的壁橱吗？嗯，你需要壁橱来放你的篮子，女士。我需要。
Your basket collection.
Give me all the baskets.
Well, listen, this little room, it was located in our writer's building.
It was on the bottom floor.
And it was an actual storage closet.
It was not a set.
So the walls did not move.
They talked about should we build Michael Scott Paper Company in the warehouse.
你的篮子收藏。把所有的篮子都给我。好吧，听着，这个小房间，它位于我们的编剧大楼里。它在底楼。它实际上是一个储藏室。它不是一个布景。所以墙壁不会移动。他们讨论过我们是否应该在仓库里建造迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。
That was my thought.
Where we've built many a set.
No.
for whatever reason, they crammed us into the post-production storage room, where previous to us
shooting in there, they had stored thousands of hours of archive tape of our show.
This was back in the day, and we just had walls and walls of five seasons of tape on our show.
They had to relocate all the tapes. They had to redress the room.
I said, the shower is fake, but those pipes were real.
我也是这么想的。我们在那里搭建过很多布景。不，不管出于什么原因，他们把我们塞进了后期制作储藏室，在我们进去拍摄之前，那里存放着我们节目数千小时的存档磁带。那是很久以前的事了，我们节目五季的磁带堆满了墙壁。他们不得不把所有的磁带都搬走。他们不得不重新布置那个房间。我说，淋浴间是假的，但那些管道是真的。
There really were these giant pipes.
Yes, the big black pipes that were coming out.
Those were real.
Yes.
Also, the bathrooms that are outside in the hallway, the two doors on either side of the Michael
Scott Paper Company door, those bathrooms were real.
Those were the actual working bathrooms for anybody who worked on the bottom floor.
Those were the bathrooms we would use in between scenes when we filmed in the warehouse.
确实有这些巨大的管道。是的，那些伸出来的大黑管子。那些是真的。是的。还有走廊外面的洗手间，迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司门两侧的那两扇门，那些洗手间也是真的。那是给所有在底层工作的人使用的真实洗手间。当我们在这个仓库拍摄时，我们在场景间隙就会使用那些洗手间。
Yes.
Are in that hallway by the editing bay.
Right across from us were our two editors,
Claire and Dave. And above us were the writers offices. So we were over in that building with the writers.
Also in this building is the lobby area that leads out into the parking lot. This room also gets
repurposed for Cafe Disco. Yes. We went back down there for that. So those are all my details on
that room. I'll have more to share as we break down the episode. More little quirks of working in there.
Yeah, you spent a lot of time in there. We did. Are you ready for
是的。就在剪辑室旁边的走廊里。我们的两位剪辑师克莱尔和戴夫就在我们对面。我们上面是编剧办公室。所以我们和编剧们在同一栋楼里。这栋楼里还有通往停车场的大厅区域。这个房间后来也被改造成了“迪斯科咖啡馆”。是的。我们为了那个场景又回到了那里。这就是关于那个房间的所有细节。等我们拆解这一集时，我会分享更多。还有更多在那里工作的小趣事。是的，你在那里待了很长时间。我们确实待了很久。你准备好听
fast fact number two. I am. Remember last week when I told you that Michael sent a letter to everybody
through NBC.com announcing his new paper company? Well, this week, he unveiled his website. An NBC created
a Michael Scott paper company website, and it had photos of the room. It was basically the same room,
taken from three different angles. It had the downloadable coupon that is shown in this episode,
you know, the one that promises unparalleled customer service that Pam and Ryan refused to copy.
And it also had the mission statement for Michael Scott Paper Company. Yes, it did. And we reached out to
Joya. You know, we've talked about Joya before. She was in charge of all the digital content
for the office that was on NBC.com. She showed.
第二个速记了吗？我准备好了。还记得上周我告诉你迈克尔通过NBC.com给每个人发了一封信，宣布他成立了新造纸公司吗？嗯，这周他发布了他的网站。NBC创建了一个迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的网站，上面有那个房间的照片。基本上就是同一个房间，从三个不同的角度拍摄的。上面有这一集中展示的可下载优惠券，你知道的，就是那张承诺提供无与伦比的客户服务，但帕姆和瑞安拒绝复印的那张。上面还有迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的使命宣言。是的，确实有。我们联系了乔亚。你知道，我们之前提到过乔亚。她负责NBC.com上所有关于《办公室》的数字内容。她向我们展示了
with us what the mission statement said. Here it is. It's the Michael Scott paper company's mission
to provide you the highest quality paper, the best possible service at the lowest possible prices.
Sounds good. Just wait. There's more. This paper business is more than just paper. More than just a
business. It's about establishing quality human relationships with our clients. While little Timmy
wakes up in the middle of the night with whooping cough and you need someone to call, we'll be there.
When sweet Christine gets stood up by her prom date, we'll be there. When the dam breaks in your backyard
and the only thing that can stop the flow of water from flooding your house is a ream of paper,
we'll be there. At the Michael Scott Paper Company, we'll always be there through thick and thin
使命宣言的内容。内容如下：迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的使命是为您提供最高质量的纸张、尽可能最好的服务以及尽可能最低的价格。听起来不错。等等，还有更多。这纸张生意不仅仅是纸张。不仅仅是一门生意。它是关于与我们的客户建立高质量的人际关系。当小蒂米在半夜因百日咳醒来，你需要有人打电话时，我们会在这里。当可爱的克里斯汀被舞伴放鸽子时，我们会在这里。当你的后院大坝决堤，唯一能阻止水流淹没你房子的是一令纸时，我们会在这里。在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，无论顺境还是逆境，我们永远都会在这里
in sickness and health till death or retirement do us part. We'll be there.
For a while, it's just pretty standard.
Kind of boilerplate.
Yeah.
But I really like it when he says we're more than just a business.
We're about quality, human relationships with our clients.
I'm like, oh.
无论生病还是健康，直到死亡或退休将我们分开。我们都会在这里。有一段时间，这听起来很标准。有点像样板文字。是的。是的。但我真的很喜欢他说我们不仅仅是一门生意。我们是关于与客户建立高质量的人际关系。我就想，哦。
And then it goes off into some very specific examples of when you might be there for me.
But in the end, I liked it.
I think I was a little curious about what kind of backyard you have that has a dam.
Well, listen.
will be there. Fast fact fact number three, Ellie Kemper is our new receptionist. Woohoo! We love Ellie. We are
definitely going to have her on the show. You know, Ellie and I both grew up in St. Louis.
I know. Now, I did not know her growing up. She is six years younger than me. I had actually
graduated college and moved to Los Angeles while she was still in high school. I'm six years
然后它列举了一些非常具体的例子，说明你可能在什么时候需要我。但最后，我喜欢它。我有点好奇你后院到底是什么样的大坝。好吧，听着。我们会在这里。速记第三条，艾莉·坎伯是我们新的前台接待员。呜呼！我们爱艾莉。我们一定会邀请她上节目。你知道，艾莉和我都是在圣路易斯长大的。我知道。现在，我小时候并不认识她。她比我小六岁。我大学毕业搬到洛杉矶时，她还在上高中。我比
older than my husband. So you just described our relationship, I guess, had we known each other back then.
By the way, do you know who her high school drama teacher was?
Ellie's? Uh-huh. No. John Ham.
Shut the front door. Yeah. John Ham also grew up in St. Louis. I also did not know John
Ham growing up, even though we were closer in age. I can't believe that was Ellie's drama teacher.
Yeah. But.
Of course, you know, Phyllis was also from St. Louis. Our director, Ken Kwapis, was from St. Louis. And our first lady, Rusty Mahmood, was from St. Louis. So we were all very excited. Well, you know, on the DVD commentary, there was a little bit of chatter. There was a little bit of chatter, Gene, and Lee, and Justin.
Hmm. Nice group. There was a little bit of chatter about which city in America was most represented in the cast and crew of the office. I think with the addition of Ellie, it became St. Louis.
我丈夫大六岁。所以你刚才描述了我们的关系，我想，如果我们当时就认识的话。顺便问一下，你知道她的高中戏剧老师是谁吗？艾莉的？嗯哼。不知道。约翰·哈姆。别开玩笑了。是的。约翰·哈姆也是在圣路易斯长大的。我小时候也不认识约翰·哈姆，尽管我们年龄相仿。我不敢相信那是艾莉的戏剧老师。是的。但是。当然，你知道，菲利斯也是来自圣路易斯。我们的导演肯·夸皮斯来自圣路易斯。我们的第一夫人拉斯蒂·马哈茂德也来自圣路易斯。所以我们都非常兴奋。嗯，你知道，在DVD评论中，有一些闲聊。有一些闲聊，吉恩、李和贾斯汀。嗯。不错的组合。有一些关于美国哪个城市在《办公室》的演员和剧组中代表性最强的闲聊。我想随着艾莉的加入，变成了圣路易斯。
It was Boston. It became St. Louis. Yes. And Jenna, I want you to know, you have clearly been a, that's going to make me laugh, obsessed with facts for a long time. I want you to hear what you brought to the DVD commentary.
R.E.D. is also from St. Louis. And so is Shannon, one of our PAs and Ken Quapis, one of our directors.
See, you said you were not going to have any fun facts. Now you're just pulling them out. So many, people are having so much fun.
with my facts.
I forgot about Shannon, who was also from St. Louis.
I know.
Well, you listed them all.
I sort of just took a snippet out.
以前是波士顿。后来变成了圣路易斯。是的。珍娜，我想让你知道，你显然一直是一个，那会让我笑，长期以来一直痴迷于事实的人。我想让你听听你在DVD评论中带来了什么。R.E.D.也来自圣路易斯。还有香农，我们的一位制片助理，以及肯·夸皮斯，我们的一位导演。看，你说你不会有任何有趣的事实。现在你只是把它们都拿出来了。这么多人，大家玩得很开心。用我的事实。我忘了香农，她也来自圣路易斯。我知道。好吧，你把它们都列出来了。我只是摘录了一小段。
You sort of talked for a while about St. Louis.
But clearly, you went into this DVD commentary saying, guys, I hope I have some fun facts.
So much so that they were like, you do have great facts.
It just cracked me up to hear you talking about your fun facts, and now you have your fast facts.
I'll tell you what, when I would go into DVD commentaries, I was often worried that I wouldn't
have anything to talk about. So I would do kind of the equivalent of a mini deep dive on something.
I wanted to come in with like an interesting tidbit that we could throw in there if there was ever a
moment where we weren't covering something about the show. This is why I love you. It goes back so
你确实谈论了一会儿圣路易斯。但很明显，你进入DVD评论时说，伙计们，我希望我有一些有趣的事实。以至于他们说，你确实有很棒的事实。听到你谈论你的有趣事实让我笑坏了，现在你有你的速记了。我告诉你，当我参加DVD评论时，我经常担心我没什么可说的。所以我会在某件事上做相当于迷你深度挖掘的事情。我想带一些有趣的片段，如果我们在节目中没有涵盖任何内容，我们可以把它扔进去。这就是我爱你的原因。这可以追溯到
far. It does, but it just got me so tickled. We had a fan question from K.J. Davy.
Aaron is my favorite character of the office. How did the producers come up with her
personality and her character as a whole and how much creative liberty did Ellie have in creating
her character's quirks and traits. KJ, Gene told me something crazy about the development of the
character of Kelly Aaron. He said that the writers had not fully fleshed out Aaron's personality
by the time we started shooting. So when we started, they had Ellie perform all of her scenes and all of her talking
heads two different ways as two different characters. I remember this. She had to do them in like that
earnest quirky way that we know and love as Erin. That's the one we eventually go with. But Gene said,
很久以前。确实，但这让我觉得很有趣。我们有一个来自K.J.戴维的粉丝提问。艾琳是我最喜欢的《办公室》角色。制片人是如何想出她的个性和整体角色的？艾莉在创造她角色的怪癖和特征方面有多少创作自由？KJ，吉恩告诉我一些关于凯利·艾琳角色发展的疯狂事情。他说，在我们开始拍摄时，编剧们还没有完全充实艾琳的个性。所以当我们开始时，他们让艾莉以两种不同的方式表演她所有的场景和所有的采访镜头，作为两个不同的角色。我记得这个。她必须以我们所知和喜爱的那种真诚、古怪的方式来表演。那是我们最终选择的版本。但吉恩说，
believe it or not, there exists a bizarro Aaron where her lines are also delivered in a no-nonsense
way. And I asked him, how long did she have to do this before they decided? And he said they definitely had
like two totally different versions of her talking heads written.
And then in her scenes with Dwight and Andy hitting on her,
she had to then perform those with different characteristics.
I mean, Gene said he gives her so much credit because this was her first big role on a TV show,
and she basically did two versions of Aaron in every scene for the entire week.
So until you shared about that sort of two versions of Aaron,
信不信由你，存在一个“异界艾琳”，她的台词也是以一种一本正经的方式表达的。我问他，在他们决定之前她必须这样做多久？他说他们肯定写了两个完全不同版本的采访镜头。然后在她和德怀特以及安迪搭讪的场景中，她必须用不同的特征来表演。我的意思是，吉恩说他非常佩服她，因为这是她在电视剧中的第一个大角色，她基本上在整个星期里每一场戏都表演了两个版本的艾琳。所以直到你分享了关于那两个版本的艾琳，
I had forgotten about it, but now there's a deleted scene that makes sense to me.
Aaron just looks at camera, you know, she's doing a talking head, and she's just like, do I have to do one of these on all of my breaks?
Yes! Angela! James Carey had the candy bag for this episode, and it included Aaron's two talking heads, neither of which end up in the episode.
Well, one of them is on the DVD.
Okay. This is the one that was in the candy bag as their first choice, which was, it's pretty cool, like any other office, I guess, phones.
computers, copiers, do I have to do this on all my breaks?
Yeah.
Is that the one that's included?
我才想起来，但现在有一个删减片段对我来说说得通了。艾琳只是看着镜头，你知道，她在做采访镜头，她就像是，我必须在所有的休息时间都做这些吗？是的！安吉拉！詹姆斯·凯里这一集有糖果袋，其中包括艾琳的两个采访镜头，这两个镜头最终都没有出现在这一集中。嗯，其中一个在DVD上。好吧。这是糖果袋里作为首选的那个，也就是，这挺酷的，像其他办公室一样，我想，电话。电脑，复印机，我必须在所有的休息时间都做这个吗？是的。那是包含在里面的那个吗？
Yeah, and I was a little confused because I thought it felt sort of off.
Then they had this, must shoot alternate, which went like this.
Most places you go, the chairs are really crappy and you're uncomfortable all day.
My chair here is great.
I really hope this works out.
And that was like the one that quirky Erin would say.
Yeah.
I guess that's our sign that the office got the new chairs.
是的，我有点困惑，因为我觉得它感觉有点不对劲。然后他们有了这个，必须拍摄的替代方案，是这样的。你去的大多数地方，椅子都很烂，你整天都不舒服。我这里的椅子很棒。我真的希望这能行。那就像古怪的艾琳会说的话。是的。我想那是我们的信号，办公室换了新椅子。
because she's loving Pam's chair.
That's it.
I think Pam finally got her new chair
and now she's working down
in Michael Scott Paper Company.
Pam talks about the chairs too later on.
I know.
I want to say that this doing two versions of your character
因为她喜欢帕姆的椅子。就是这样。我想帕姆终于得到了她的新椅子，现在她在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司工作。帕姆后来也谈到了椅子。我知道。我想说，这种表演两个版本的角色
happened to me on the film Blades of Glory.
Really?
Yeah, I had gone in with this idea
for this version of the character
that was based kind of on like
Bernadette Peters' performance and the jerk.
Yeah?
I just really loved her wide-eyed, innocent, earnest,
在我拍摄电影《冰刀双人组》时也发生过。真的吗？是的，我带着这个想法去参加那个角色的试镜，这个角色有点基于伯纳黛特·彼得斯在《傻瓜》中的表演。是吗？我真的很喜欢她那种睁大眼睛、天真、真诚的
approach to love and sex and just sort of all of it and being with sort of an oddball guy.
And that is very similar to my character of Katie and Blades of Glory.
But I think there was a little bit of concern that that might feel like too big of a choice.
And so they also had me do all the scenes just pretty straight.
And I did that for a couple of days, every scene.
And eventually they went with my quirky version.
I was so proud, but it was super intense because I remember one day I was shooting the scene with Will Arnett and Amy Polar.
They played a brother-sister ice skating duo.
对待爱情和性的方式，以及所有这一切，还有和那种古怪的家伙在一起。这和我《冰刀双人组》中凯蒂的角色非常相似。但我认为有一点担心，这可能感觉选择太大了。所以他们也让我把所有的场景都演得很直白。我那样做了几天，每一场戏。最终他们选择了我的古怪版本。我感到非常自豪，但这超级紧张，因为我记得有一天我在和威尔·阿奈特和艾米·波勒拍戏。他们扮演一对兄妹花样滑冰组合。
Yeah, I remember.
And their little sister slash assistant.
Oh my God, it was so much fun shooting with those guys.
That whole movie looked like a blast.
I know.
The cast looked like so much fun.
We had a blast.
But we had this scene and they were like, okay, we're.
是的，我记得。还有他们的小妹妹兼助理。天哪，和那些家伙一起拍摄太有趣了。整部电影看起来都很有趣。我知道。演员阵容看起来很有趣。我们玩得很开心。但我们有这场戏，他们说，好吧，我们要
going to lunch, Jenna, you get two takes, one in one version and one in the other. And I had to
just nail both versions. And I remember someone, and I can't remember who came up to me early,
and they were like, just don't do a good job of the version you don't want to have them pick.
Just do the version you like really well. Tank one of them. Yeah. And then they'll be forced
to go with, you know, your vision of the character. I couldn't do it. My like, actor integrity.
No, just your whole moral compass.
You could never do that.
I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it.
去吃午饭了，珍娜，你有两次拍摄机会，一个版本一次。我必须把两个版本都演好。我记得有人，我不记得是谁，很早就来找我，他们说，不要把你不想让他们选的版本演好。只把你喜欢的那个版本演好。搞砸其中一个。是的。然后他们将被迫选择，你知道，你对角色的设想。我做不到。我的那种，演员的正直。不，只是你整个道德指南针。你永远做不到那样。我做不到。我做不到。
It is interesting to me how characters become like who they are on a show or in a movie.
This is reminding me of a project that one of my friends wrote.
It was based on a real life story from her life.
And she had this character of a guy named Ed.
And he was based on her friend in real life, Ed.
And Ed was also an actor.
So Ed went in to audition for Ed.
So he's in front of the network
角色是如何在节目或电影中变成他们现在的样子的，这对我来说很有趣。这让我想起了一个朋友写的一个项目。它是基于她生活中的一个真实故事。她有一个叫埃德的角色。他是基于她现实生活中的朋友埃德。埃德也是一名演员。所以埃德去为埃德试镜。所以他在网络面前
And he's like, hi, I'm Ed, I'm reading for Ed.
And he just was himself.
She wrote him as himself.
We were all like, Ed's going to get the part of Ed, right?
I mean, they wrote it for Ed.
And he didn't get it.
I was like, how can Ed not get Ed?
It's based on Ed.
他说，嗨，我是埃德，我正在为埃德读剧本。他只是做他自己。她把他写成他自己。我们都说，埃德会得到埃德的角色，对吧？我的意思是，他们是为埃德写的。但他没得到。我说，埃德怎么可能得不到埃德？它是基于埃德的。
Like, what?
Lady, I have a very similar story.
Okay, I auditioned for this lead role in a pilot opposite Dan Finnerty.
He's from the Dan Band.
Yeah, yeah.
It was hilarious.
And when I read the role, I thought to myself, oh, this is so Mary Lynn Ricegub.
And so I went in and I just did my best impression of Mary Lynn.
就像，什么？女士，我有一个非常相似的故事。好吧，我为一个飞行员剧集中的主角试镜，对手是丹·芬纳蒂。他来自丹乐队。是的，是的。这太搞笑了。当我读到这个角色时，我心想，哦，这太像玛丽·琳·莱斯格布了。所以我进去了，我只是尽我所能模仿玛丽·琳。
I love Mary Lynn.
I know.
I have worked with her many times.
I love her.
I super copied her.
I get to the final audition.
It's me and two other women.
One of them is like a tall, gorgeous blonde.
我爱玛丽·琳。我知道。我和她合作过很多次。我爱她。我超级模仿她。我到了最后的试镜。是我和另外两个女人。其中一个是高个子、华丽的金发女郎。
The other one is Mary Lynn Ricegub.
Then I find out that,
Dan knows Mary Lynn and he wrote the role for her. Any wonder? Well, I was proud of myself because I was like,
well, I guess I nailed it on what he was going for. He was going for Mary Lynn. Did Mary Lynn get it?
No, neither of us did. They gave it to the blonde. Oh, no. I know. And it was so funny because
I thought to myself, well, obviously they're going to go with Mary Lynn. They're not going to go with me.
I'm copying her. Right. They didn't give it to either of us. But the two of us were at least,
doing what he intended when he wrote it. Yeah. No, they went the other way. You never know. You never know.
另一个是玛丽·琳·莱斯格布。然后我发现，丹认识玛丽·琳，他为她写了这个角色。有什么好奇怪的？好吧，我为自己感到骄傲，因为我想，好吧，我想我抓住了他想要的东西。他想要的是玛丽·琳。玛丽·琳得到了吗？不，我们俩都没得到。他们把它给了那个金发女郎。哦，不。我知道。这太搞笑了，因为我心想，好吧，显然他们会选择玛丽·琳。他们不会选择我。我在模仿她。对。他们没给我们要中的任何一个。但我们俩至少在做他写的时候打算做的事情。是的。不，他们选择了另一个方向。你永远不知道。你永远不知道。
Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will really get into this episode. I have a lot of
fun stuff this week, I think. Me too. I have some sunglasses information. Hold up. I have
sunglasses information. Oh my God. What if we have the same sunglasses information?
Whose sunglasses are you going to talk about? Two different people's sunglasses. I have
photo evidence of somebody's sunglasses.
I have photo evidence of somebody's.
Oh my gosh.
This is how you guys know that we don't talk to each other.
好吧，我们休息一下吧？当我们回来时，我们将真正进入这一集。我想这周我有很多有趣的东西。我也是。我有一些太阳镜的信息。等等。我有太阳镜的信息。天哪。如果我们有相同的太阳镜信息怎么办？你要谈论谁的太阳镜？两个不同人的太阳镜。我有某人太阳镜的照片证据。我有某人的照片证据。天哪。这就是你们知道我们不互相交谈的方式。
We show up and try to surprise each other.
And sometimes we find the same things.
We'll be back.
What the heck is going on with all these promotional popcorn buckets?
The giant shorts that all of Gen Z is wearing now and whatever the heck,
Hirocks is?
I'm comedian and conservative.
certified hater Matt Bellasai, and these are the types of questions I'm demanding answers to on my
我们出现并试图给对方惊喜。有时我们发现同样的事情。我们会回来的。所有这些促销爆米花桶到底是怎么回事？现在所有Z世代都在穿的巨大短裤，以及不管什么鬼，Hirocks是什么？我是喜剧演员和保守派。认证的仇恨者马特·贝拉赛，这些是我要求在我的
podcast, What the Heck with Matt Bellasai? Listen or watch every Thursday as I rant about all the
internet trends, pop culture stories, and personal mayhem that makes me scream, what the heck? Follow
What the Heck with Matt Bellasai wherever you get your podcasts. We are back and this episode
opens with Michael driving up in his convertible. He's got the top down. He's blasting his music. He's
blasting his music. Yeah. It's Brittany bitch. But it's Lady Gaga. Exactly. Yeah. It's Lady Gaga
singing just dance. But it's Britney bitch. At 18 seconds, I caught the camera crew in Michael's sunglasses.
You did? Yep. Go to 18 seconds. You can see our camera crew in his sunglasses. You guys,
there was some debate about Michael's sunglasses. Oh, we're already into the sunglasses info.
播客《马特·贝拉赛的到底怎么回事？》中得到答案的问题。每周四收听或观看，我都会咆哮所有互联网趋势、流行文化故事和让我尖叫“到底怎么回事？”的个人混乱。在任何你获取播客的地方关注《马特·贝拉赛的到底怎么回事？》。我们回来了，这一集以迈克尔开着敞篷车出现开始。他把车顶放下来了。他在播放他的音乐。他在播放他的音乐。是的。是布兰妮碧池。但那是Lady Gaga。完全正确。是的。是Lady Gaga唱的《Just Dance》。但那是布兰妮碧池。在18秒时，我在迈克尔的太阳镜里捕捉到了摄像组。你捕捉到了？是的。去18秒。你可以在他的太阳镜里看到我们的摄像组。伙计们，关于迈克尔的太阳镜有一些争论。哦，我们已经进入太阳镜信息了。
It's right out of the gate.
They couldn't decide.
Two things.
One, should he leave the sunglasses on the whole time?
Mm-hmm.
Or should he take them off?
Okay.
They decided it's better for comedy if your sunglasses are off.
就在大门外。他们无法决定。两件事。第一，他应该一直戴着太阳镜吗？嗯哼。还是他应该摘下来？好吧。他们决定如果摘下太阳镜对喜剧效果更好。
Because you use your face, you guys.
Okay.
Right?
Number two, they were trying to debate between the pair of sunglasses they picked
or a pair that were really popular at the time that P. Diddy was wearing.
Oh.
Okay.
And they picked not.
因为你们要用脸，伙计们。好吧。对吧？第二，他们试图在他们挑选的太阳镜和当时非常流行、P. Diddy戴的那副太阳镜之间进行辩论。哦。好吧。他们没选那个。
P. Diddy's glasses. That's right. So they picked not P. Diddy's glasses, but to also take them off
for the sake of comedy. Well, at 32 seconds, Michael is going to try to parallel park. He is going to do
unsuccessfully. There's just not enough room. I love what he said, not going to make this one.
There's like three car lengths of curb available. Randy Cordray told us that we did this in cuts.
So first, they padded the rear bumper of Michael's PT cruiser so that it wouldn't actually damage the car behind him.
They shot it in a way so you can't see the padding.
When Michael pulls away, they had removed the foam cushioning, and that crunch you hear was a special effects sound that they added in post.
Well, I thought it was a really relatable moment because I know I've bailed mid-parallel park before.
P. Diddy的眼镜。没错。所以他们选的不是P. Diddy的眼镜，而是为了喜剧效果把它们摘下来。在32秒时，迈克尔要尝试侧方停车。他尝试失败了。空间实在不够。我喜欢他说的那句“这车停不进去”。路边明明有三个车位的长度。兰迪·科德雷告诉我们，这一幕是分段拍摄的。首先，他们给迈克尔的PT漫步者后保险杠加了衬垫，这样就不会真的撞坏后面的车。拍摄时避开了衬垫。当迈克尔开走时，他们移除了泡沫垫，你听到的碰撞声是后期添加的特效。我觉得这一幕很有共鸣，因为我知道我以前也曾在侧方停车中途放弃过。
Especially if you're trying to parallel park somewhere where people are like eating outside.
like, and they're watching you.
They're all watching you do that.
Eat, or, eat, eat, eat.
Like trying to back in, and then you're just like, forget it.
Bailing.
When I went to take my driving test, I was about to fail.
The last task was Parallel Park.
特别是如果你试图在有人在外面吃饭的地方侧方停车，他们都在看着你。他们都在看着你停车。吃啊，吃啊，吃啊。就像试图倒车进去，然后你就会想，算了。放弃吧。我参加驾照考试时，差点没过。最后一项任务就是侧方停车。
Same.
And I nailed it.
And I passed my driving test.
Yeah, same here.
I was doing horribly, but Coach Wolfe, who taught me driver's ed,
had really worked with me on parallel parking.
My dad had really worked with me on parallel parking.
Does this make us sound like bad drivers that parallel parking saved us?
我也是。我一次就成功了。我通过了驾照考试。我也是。我当时表现得很糟糕，但教我驾驶课的沃尔夫教练在侧方停车上给了我很多指导。我爸爸也在这方面帮了我很多。这听起来是不是像我们开车技术很烂，全靠侧方停车才过关的？
Well, here's the thing.
Ironically, I do not get an actual car accidents, but I am constantly hitting things when I'm trying to park.
I know.
I've seen you like get real close to hitting something when you were parking one time.
I was like, Jenna, Jenna, Jenna.
Yeah.
Well, when I took my driver's ed test, the tester guy, he wrote a little note on my test.
score. What did it say? Very distracted. Distracted. Because when he was giving me my driver's ed test,
是这样的。讽刺的是，我其实没出过真正的车祸，但我停车时总是会撞到东西。我知道。有一次我看到你停车时差点撞到东西。我当时心想，珍娜，珍娜，珍娜。是的。当我参加驾驶课考试时，考官在我的成绩单上写了一条小备注。写了什么？“非常分心”。分心。因为当他给我进行驾驶测试时，
we drove down the little main street of the small town I'm from. And my friends were all hanging
out at this car wash that had gone out of business. People would park their cars there and hang out,
like teenagers. And a bunch of my friends were parked there. And they all knew I was taking my
test. And so as I drove by, I honked and waved. And my test started. And my testers.
guy did not like that. But you still pass. I still pass because of parallel parking.
Well, also arriving this morning to the Scranton Business Park is Ryan and Jim and Pam are walking in.
Pam and her blazer. And her new plant alert. I know. People wrote in about the plant, Angela.
It's the first thing I noticed. 42 seconds. Spotted a potted plant is what I wrote in my notes.
我们开车经过我老家那条小镇的主街。我的朋友们都聚在一家倒闭的洗车店那里。青少年们常把车停在那里闲逛。我的一群朋友就在那儿。他们都知道我在考试。所以我开车经过时，按了喇叭还挥了手。我的测试开始了。我的考官不喜欢那样。但你还是通过了。我还是通过了，多亏了侧方停车。另外，今天早上来到斯克兰顿商业园的还有瑞安，吉姆和帕姆也走了进来。帕姆穿着她的西装外套。还有她的新盆栽警报。我知道。人们写信问起那盆植物，安吉拉。这是我注意到的第一件事。42秒。我在笔记里写着：发现一盆盆栽。
very cute and it's going to stay on the little desk in Michael Scott Paper Company.
Well, for a long time, we've wondered who would bring in the potted plants at reception.
I guess this solves it. It was Pam. It was Pam.
While Pam and Jim are walking into the parking lot, Michael has wedged his car between two other cars
and he's trying to shimmy out over the back. Holding the Cheetos, by the way.
Yes. Jenna, Steve ripped his pants in the scene.
He did. Yeah. He was trying to see.
scooch over the back of the PT cruiser and his pants got hung up on the back of the little convertible
非常可爱，它会一直放在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的那个小桌子上。长期以来，我们一直好奇前台的盆栽是谁带来的。我想这下解开了。是帕姆。是帕姆。当帕姆和吉姆走进停车场时，迈克尔把他的车挤在两辆车中间，正试图从后备箱爬出来。顺便说一下，手里还拿着奇多。是的。珍娜，史蒂夫在这一幕里把裤子撕破了。确实。是的。他试图从PT漫步者的后部爬出来，裤子被那辆敞篷小车的后部挂住了，
part. And he's scooching. It's in the bloopers. And I was going to play it. But the majority of the
bloopers is Steve scooching and grunting trying to get over the back hump of the car. And then he
finally says, I'm going to need a new pair of pants. Oh, it just made me laugh. You know what?
I'll put the blooper in our stories because it's really one you have to watch to appreciate.
Now we go to our opening credits, and they are all new this episode in honor of Michael Scott
Paper Company. I was very excited for you. I was like, oh, I bet Jenna has a whole breakdown,
because you've done a whole thing about the opening credits. First of all, I did not remember
this. So when this came on, I was so delighted, and then all the memories came flooding back
那部分。他在挪动。这在花絮里。我本来想放出来的。但大部分花絮都是史蒂夫在挪动和哼哼，试图翻过车后的隆起。最后他说：“我需要一条新裤子。”哦，这真的让我大笑。你知道吗？我会把花絮放到我们的故事里，因为这真的需要亲眼看才能体会。现在进入片头，这一集为了向迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司致敬，片头全是新的。我为你感到非常兴奋。我心想，哦，我敢打赌珍娜一定会进行全面解析，因为你之前对片头做过专门的研究。首先，我完全不记得这个了。所以当它出现时，我非常惊喜，然后所有的回忆都涌了回来，
of us filming these new opening credits. They were also not in the script. This was Mindy Kaling's
idea. Lee and Jean said,
they absolutely loved getting to shoot them and they really tried to match the tone and style of
the original main titles. So I did a whole breakdown of the Michael Scott Paper Company main titles
and our usual main titles. And they match up almost shot for shot. It's pretty cool.
That's awesome. I have some fun tidbits about some of the things we saw in those opening credits.
Okay. First of all, the goldfish on Michael's desk. Oh yeah. This all happens about one minute,
18 seconds, right? There's a great overview of the whole room. We got a fan mail flurry about this goldfish
关于我们拍摄这些新片头。它们也不在剧本里。这是敏迪·卡灵的主意。李和吉恩说，他们非常喜欢拍摄这些镜头，并且真的试图匹配原版片头的基调和风格。所以我对迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的片头和我们平时的片头做了一个完整的对比。它们几乎是逐个镜头对应的。这太酷了。太棒了。关于我们在片头中看到的一些东西，我有一些有趣的细节。好的。首先，迈克尔桌子上的金鱼。哦，是的。这一切发生在大约1分18秒，对吧？有一个房间的全景。我们收到了很多关于这条金鱼的粉丝来信，
lady. Oh, yeah? Remember last week, we talked about the Jerry McGuire goldfish and how Michael and Pam had
their Jerry McGuire moment. Well, Michael is going to have a goldfish on his desk now. But fan mail flurry
points out that there is going to be a different goldfish every time we cut to a shot of Michael's desk.
And there is a reason for that.
Randy Cordray said this was an Easter egg that they planted in these episodes.
It's never talked about.
But the idea was that Michael could not keep this fish alive.
Randy told me that every Friday they would give the goldfish to a crew member who wanted it.
女士。哦，是吗？记得上周我们谈到《甜心先生》里的金鱼，以及迈克尔和帕姆如何拥有了他们的《甜心先生》时刻吗？现在迈克尔的桌子上要放一条金鱼了。但粉丝来信指出，每次切换到迈克尔桌子的镜头时，金鱼都不一样。这是有原因的。兰迪·科德雷说这是他们在这些剧集中埋下的彩蛋。从来没人提过。但想法是迈克尔根本养不活这条鱼。兰迪告诉我，每个星期五他们都会把金鱼送给想要它的剧组成员。
And then they would replace it with a new fish for the next episode.
So moving forward, folks, I will track the fish.
It starts as your standard orange goldfish.
Okay.
Goldfish tracker.
Next up, I would really like to talk about the stapler that BJ is using in the opening credits.
It is a paper pro stapler, and we were obsessed with it in Michael Scott Paper Company.
Obsessed.
然后他们会为下一集换一条新鱼。所以，伙计们，接下来我会追踪这条鱼。它最初是一条普通的橙色金鱼。好的。金鱼追踪器。接下来，我真的很想谈谈BJ在片头里用的订书机。那是Paper Pro订书机，我们在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司时对它着迷不已。着迷。
Why?
It is the greatest stapler you will ever use ever.
Phil Shea let me keep one.
I still have it.
You do not have to push on it the way BJ is in the opening credits.
He is operating the stapler incorrectly.
you just give it a little squeeze and the air pressure, some sort of mechanism, makes it staple perfectly.
I looked it up. Here's how it is described.
为什么？它是你用过的最棒的订书机，没有之一。菲尔·谢让我留了一个。我现在还有。你不需要像BJ在片头里那样用力按。他操作订书机的方法不对。你只需要轻轻一压，空气压力，某种机制，就能让它完美地装订。我查了一下。它是这样描述的。
Okay.
The paper pro is the first engineering breakthrough in staplers since, well, the stapler.
Push it with one finger's worth of effort and a spring-loaded mechanism drives the staple with 30 pounds of force
through up to 20 sheets of paper.
Wow.
We loved that stapler.
We loved it.
Of all the things I thought we would talk about today,
好的。Paper Pro是自订书机发明以来，订书机领域的第一个工程突破。用一根手指的力气按下去，弹簧加载机制就能产生30磅的力，一次穿透多达20张纸。哇。我们爱死那个订书机了。我们爱死它了。在今天我们要谈论的所有事情中，
I did not think we'd talk about a super air pressure powered stapler.
I recommend it.
I'm dying to use one.
Finally, the copier that you see in the opening credits and throughout this episode is the broken copier from the surplus.
I love that written on the side it says trash.
I know. That copier is just haunting Pam. She's lost her comfortable chair and now she's back with this horrible copier. What has she done to her life? You know that was sitting out by the dumpsters. They wrote trash on it and set it out. Ah. So right at the beginning of their first day of the Michael Scott Paper Company, there would have been a series of talking heads. Ryan had one. Michael had one. Pam had one about her first day.
And I thought it was really sweet and also made me a little curious.
I think we need to hear it.
我没想到我们会谈论一个超级气压驱动的订书机。我推荐它。我迫不及待想用一个。最后，你在片头和整集中看到的复印机就是从剩余物资里拿来的那台坏掉的复印机。我喜欢它侧面写着“垃圾”字样。我知道。那台复印机简直在折磨帕姆。她失去了舒适的椅子，现在又回到了这台糟糕的复印机身边。她的人生到底经历了什么？你知道那是放在垃圾桶旁边的。他们写上“垃圾”然后把它扔在那儿。啊。所以，在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司开业的第一天，应该有一系列采访镜头。瑞安有一个。迈克尔有一个。帕姆有一个关于她第一天的感受。我觉得这很甜，也让我有点好奇。我想我们需要听听。
Embarking on a new adventure.
There was a fork in the road and I took the road less traveled.
Never traveled.
Not even a road, really.
More of a path with a sign that says those who pass shall die and a skull and crossbones.
The other road was kind of like Putnam Road.
That's a really boring road in Scranton.
So these were the two paths that you were.
踏上一段新的冒险。路口出现了分叉，我选择了人迹罕至的那条路。从来没人走过。甚至算不上路，更像是一条小径，上面挂着牌子写着“擅入者死”，还有骷髅和交叉骨头。另一条路有点像普特南路。那是斯克兰顿一条非常无聊的路。所以这就是你当时面临的两条路。
choosing between. But guys, in Scranton, I Google image Putnam Road. It looks like a fine road.
Here's something crazy. I worked at Putnam Investments as an executive secretary for years. That was my
last full-time job I had as an executive assistant before I was able to earn my living full-time
as an actor. Woo! Yeah. That's a full-circle life moment. Well, back upstairs, you know,
this is such a funny scene. Kelly is sort of leaning up on Jim's desk and she's just sort of mumbling things.
Like Jim's like, you were, you're not really talking to me. She is just waiting for Charles to say Kelly.
And then she runs in and she's like, you wanted me? And he's like, no, no, no, I meant that Kelly. And this is when we meet Aaron. Yes. Jim has this fantastic talking head that he says that Kelly thinks if she says you wanted me enough that Charles.
Charles will, in fact, want her. It's not the worst plan she's ever had.
选择。但是伙计们，在斯克兰顿，我谷歌了普特南路的图片。看起来是一条不错的路。这里有个疯狂的事实。我在普特南投资公司当了多年的行政秘书。那是我在能够以演员为全职职业谋生之前，最后一份全职行政助理工作。呜！是的。这是一个人生圆满的时刻。回到楼上，你知道，这一幕太搞笑了。凯利靠在吉姆的桌子上，嘟囔着一些话。吉姆就像是说，你，你不是真的在跟我说话。她只是在等查尔斯叫凯利。然后她跑进去说，你找我？他说，不，不，不，我指的是那个凯利。这就是我们见到艾琳的时候。是的。吉姆有一个精彩的采访镜头，他说凯利认为如果她多说几次“你找我”，查尔斯就会真的想要她。这还不是她想出的最烂的计划。
Lady, this made me think. Like, this is like self-fulfilling prophecy.
Like, Kelly is using self-fulfilling prophecy. My mom used to have this saying, and I think it's like,
paraphrasing scripture and proverbs, but speak of what is not as if it were so, and it shall become.
And I think I was like sort of in a very deep place when I was watching this episode. I had some
things in my life that I had sort of written out, like something I was meditating about,
praying about, and it was coming to fruition. And I was trying to plant these seeds of like
positive good intention, right? To then have this great harvest of this good thing. And when you
watch the office through that filter, you're like, Kelly, Kelly is practicing self-fulfilling
女士，这让我想到。这就像是自我实现的预言。凯利在利用自我实现的预言。我妈妈以前常说一句话，我想这是在引用圣经和箴言，但大意是：谈论那些不存在的事物，就好像它们已经存在一样，它们就会实现。我想我在看这一集时，处于一种非常深刻的状态。我生活中有些事情是我写下来的，比如我正在冥想、祈祷的事情，它们正在实现。我试图播下这些积极、美好意图的种子，对吧？然后收获这些美好事物的丰收。当你通过这个滤镜看《办公室》时，你会觉得，凯利，凯利正在实践自我实现的
prophecy. It's great. I use that all the time. We talk about that. Yeah. I mean, just in the
formation of this podcast, we must have said what we wanted for two years before we developed this show
and signed a contract. Speak the positive. Speak it. I always say when you blow out your birthday candles,
you should tell everyone your wish because the more people who know, there's more people invested in
helping you make it come true. Yeah. Share your wishes. Share it. I love that. I had to share that. Well, I have got a bit of a
bombshell regarding this scene.
What?
A full bombshell.
预言。这太棒了。我一直都在用。我们谈论过这个。是的。我的意思是，仅仅是在这个播客的筹备过程中，我们在开发这个节目并签署合同之前，肯定已经说了两年我们想要什么。说出积极的话。说出来。我总是说，当你吹灭生日蜡烛时，你应该告诉每个人你的愿望，因为知道的人越多，就有更多人投入到帮助你实现愿望中。是的。分享你的愿望。分享出来。我喜欢这个。我必须分享一下。好吧，关于这一幕我有一个重磅消息。什么？一个完整的重磅消息。
What?
So, you know, Charles says, I wasn't talking about you, Kelly.
I was talking about the other Kelly.
And they eventually settle on the fact that they will call the second Kelly by her middle name, Aaron.
Yeah.
The original name for Ellie's character.
What?
The one that appears in the table draft.
什么？所以，你知道，查尔斯说，我不是在说你，凯利。我说的是另一个凯利。他们最终决定用第二个凯利的中间名来称呼她，即艾琳。是的。艾莉角色的最初名字。什么？出现在剧本草稿里的那个。
What?
Was not Kelly.
It was not Aaron.
Her name was Mary.
Mary.
Yeah.
And this scene was not a thing where they have the same name.
That was a late edition.
什么？不是凯利。也不是艾琳。她的名字叫玛丽。玛丽。是的。而且这一幕并不是关于她们名字相同的情节。那是后来加进去的。
Oh, wow.
I love the scene.
I know, me too.
Well, fan question from Kelly Ann M.
Who says,
We need to track Aaron's hair progression.
When did she go red?
She will eventually win cutest redhead in the office,
哦，哇。我喜欢这一幕。我知道，我也是。好吧，来自凯利·安·M的粉丝提问。她说，我们需要追踪艾琳的发色变化。她是什么时候染成红色的？她最终会赢得办公室最可爱红发女郎的称号，
but she's a brunette here.
We need to track it.
Well, Lee Eisenberg filled me in on this.
Well, I remember some of this.
He said when Ellie showed up for her very first day of work, her hair color was almost identical to mine.
Yep.
And everyone freaked out.
They were not trying to tell a story that Pam was being replaced by a sort of lookalike person.
但她在这里是棕发。我们需要追踪它。好吧，李·艾森伯格告诉了我这件事。我记得一些。他说当艾莉第一天上班时，她的发色和我的几乎一模一样。是的。每个人都吓坏了。他们并不是想讲一个帕姆被一个长相相似的人取代的故事。
And they were really worried that if they put her on camera, having the same color,
hair that it was going to tell a story they weren't telling. Yeah. So they had to change the whole
schedule for the day and color her hair. I was in the hair and makeup trailer when she was getting her
hair colored by Kim Ferry. And I guess Kim just has a drawer of hair color. Sure. And they came up with
this sort of brunette color, which will now evolve. The character of Aaron was also not originally
meant to become a full-time regular character. This was just going to be a few episodes. So we will track it. But I believe her hair is going to get to sort of change over to that red color as they make her a more permanent character on the show. Yeah, I remember that day. And Ellie is such a team player, you know. And my memory's correct. They died at one time and then died it again. Oh, boy. Yeah. Oh, boy.
Michael Scott Paper Company has kind of come already to a standstill.
They don't know what to do.
他们真的很担心如果让她上镜，发色一样会传达出他们没想表达的故事。是的。所以他们不得不改变当天的整个时间表，给她的头发染色。当金·费里给她染发时，我就在化妆车里。我想金只是有一个装染发剂的抽屉。当然。他们想出了这种棕色，现在会演变。艾琳这个角色最初也不打算成为全职常驻角色。这本来只是几集的戏份。所以我们会追踪它。但我相信随着她成为剧中的常驻角色，她的头发会变成那种红色。是的，我记得那天。艾莉真是个团队合作者，你知道。如果我的记忆没错，他们染了一次，然后又染了一次。天哪。是的。天哪。迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司已经陷入了停滞。他们不知道该做什么。
They're like, what do we do now?
They're just sitting there looking at each other.
Yeah, Michael's working on his Evite for his pancake luncheon.
We had a fan catch from Ria V and Abby M who noticed, if you look closely,
it says that the luncheon is going to take place on Saturday.
I saw that too.
Also, during this scene, you can hear the sounds of toilets flushing through the pipes over.
head, you're really getting a sense of this workspace. So we could actually hear toilets flushing
他们就像是，我们现在该做什么？他们只是坐在那里看着对方。是的，迈克尔正在为他的煎饼午餐会制作电子邀请函。我们收到了来自Ria V和Abby M的粉丝发现，如果你仔细看，上面写着午餐会将在周六举行。我也看到了。此外，在这一幕中，你可以听到头顶管道里马桶冲水的声音，你真的能感受到这个工作空间。所以我们真的能听到马桶冲水的声音，
if somebody used the real bathrooms outside. So while we were shooting, they would not allow anyone in there.
But while we rehearsed or while we were waiting to shoot, people could use the bathrooms. And so we
would really sit in that room and hear flushing toilets. And I also don't know if you noticed the spots that
BJ and I are sitting in. When we first walked into that room, our natural inclination was to sit
across from one another at the table because it gave you maximum space for your elbows.
Sure, sure. But you couldn't shoot us that way. We had to both sort of sit with our backs,
like scrunched up against that wall kind of next to each other facing Michael because it was
literally the only way to get us on camera. Last week in Dream Team for the DVD Commentary
如果有人用了外面真正的洗手间的话。所以当我们拍摄时，他们不允许任何人进去。但在我们排练或等待拍摄时，人们可以使用洗手间。所以我们真的会坐在那个房间里听到冲马桶的声音。我不知道你是否注意到了BJ和我坐的位置。当我们第一次走进那个房间时，我们的自然倾向是坐在桌子对面，因为那样可以给我们的手肘留出最大的空间。当然，当然。但那样拍不到我们。我们必须都背对着墙，挤在一起，面对着迈克尔，因为这真的是在镜头里拍到我们的唯一方法。上周在DVD评论的《梦之队》那一集中，
for that episode. Matt Sone actually talked about this episode and how hard it was to shoot in that
room because of the angles. Exactly what you were talking about. They kept catching each other.
Our two camera operators kept catching each other in the shot. So they had to sort of position
you guys so that they could get these single camera shots of you. Yeah, I think that's something
you don't think about when you watch the scene is how there's all these extra people in the room.
Yeah. But they're magically avoiding one another on camera. But at the same time, Steve is Michael can't walk from
his desk to the poker table without balking his leg into things. You know, it's like that tight.
Well, now Michael is going to ask Pam to make 800 copies of his unparalleled customer service
马特·索恩谈到了这一集，以及因为角度问题在那个房间拍摄有多难。正是你刚才说的。他们一直在互相穿帮。我们的两个摄像师一直在镜头里拍到对方。所以他们不得不把你们安排好，以便能拍到你们的单人镜头。是的，我想这是你在看这一幕时不会想到的，房间里有这么多额外的人。是的。但他们在镜头里神奇地避开了彼此。但与此同时，史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔如果不把腿撞到东西上，就没法从桌子走到扑克桌。你知道，就是那么挤。好吧，现在迈克尔要让帕姆复印800份他的无与伦比的客户服务
coupon, but Pam has a talking head and I really relate to this. She says, if I make this one copy,
then I'll become the girl who makes copies, and then I'm basically a receptionist again.
And I don't know if you noticed where the phone was on that table, but it is right in front of Pam.
So she's already clearly closest to the phone.
And even later when it rings, Michael says, answer it.
I know.
Right? Yeah.
She's really trying to break out of this role of receptionist, and she refuses to make the copy.
优惠券，但帕姆有一个采访镜头，我真的很有共鸣。她说，如果我复印了这一份，那我就成了那个复印的女孩，然后我就基本上又是个前台了。我不知道你有没有注意到桌上的电话在哪里，它就在帕姆面前。所以她显然离电话最近。甚至后来电话响的时候，迈克尔说，接电话。我知道，对吧？是的。她真的在努力摆脱前台的角色，她拒绝复印。
She doesn't want to go down Putnam Road, guys.
She doesn't.
She wants the other path, the more exciting path.
Well, it's a pretty big day for a few other characters at Dundermifflin.
Dwight is going to take Andy hunting.
They're like buddy buddy.
There's so much more of this scene where they're sort of wrestling and like doing all this stuff.
It goes on for so long.
伙计们，她不想走帕特南路。她不想。她想要另一条路，那条更刺激的路。好吧，对于邓德米夫林的其他几位角色来说，这可是重要的一天。德怀特要带安迪去打猎。他们就像好哥们一样。这一幕里还有很多他们摔跤之类的戏份。持续了很长时间。
I have no doubt.
Do not ask the fellas to roughhouse or wrestle in a scene unless you want to have an hour of additional footage of it.
Because anytime they had Rain Wilson and John Krasinski have to do something like that, like last week's knock, knock joke thing, any scuffle.
It's worth a watch in the deleted scenes because those two fellas go for so long in all their fake different ways of attacking each other.
And they get so into John's personal space.
And his face is hilarious.
I don't know how he kept a straight face.
Andy had a talking head that was deleted where he talks about this bromance.
我一点也不怀疑。千万别让这帮家伙在戏里打闹或摔跤，除非你想多出几个小时的素材。因为每次雷恩·威尔森和约翰·卡拉辛斯基要拍这种戏，比如上周的敲门笑话，或者任何推搡戏，都值得去看看删减片段，因为那两个家伙在各种假装攻击对方的戏码上能演好久。他们甚至侵入了约翰的私人空间。他的表情太搞笑了。我不知道他是怎么忍住不笑场的。安迪有一个被删掉的采访片段，他在里面谈到了这段兄弟情。
You know, we see Dwight's in the episode.
But Andy had a counterpart one and I think we need to hear it.
Oh.
Let me tell you something.
When Angel and I split, ha, oh, I went through it, big time.
Lost my high notes.
Top of my range was like, b'b.
Then I took some time.
你知道，我们在剧集里看到了德怀特的部分。但安迪也有一个对应的采访，我觉得我们需要听听。哦。让我告诉你一件事。当安吉拉和我分手时，哈，哦，我经历了一段非常艰难的时期。失去了我的高音。我的音域上限就像是，b'b。然后我花了一些时间。
I got my heel on.
I got some perspective on.
And I found a new friend in the most unlikely of places.
The enemy been.
And now, I...
He got his high notes back.
He did.
He got his heel on.
我振作起来了。我换了个角度看问题。我在最不可能的地方找到了一个新朋友。那个敌人箱。现在，我……他找回了他的高音。没错。他振作起来了。
He got his perspective on.
And he found it all on the enemy bin.
I know.
I also really love the storyline of Charles asking Jim for the rundown.
Yes.
And Jim has no idea what a rundown is.
And he's not going to ask.
He's too afraid.
他换了个角度看问题。他在敌人箱里找到了这一切。我知道。我也非常喜欢查尔斯让吉姆交出工作总结的剧情。是的。吉姆根本不知道什么是工作总结。而且他不敢问。他太害怕了。
I know.
So when we reached out to Jean and Lee, they said that this whole rundown story was a late edition.
It was part of a rewrite session.
And you know, we've talked about how some of the writers would break off into these little pods.
So Paul Lieberstein, Jen Salata, and B.J. Novak broke away from the group. And in about two hours, they came up with this whole rundown storyline. I love it. I know. And then Justin Spitzer said, they thought this was great. This sort of rundown was sort of this vague term. And no one in the writer's room really knew what it meant. So they thought, well, that's perfect. Maybe Jim wouldn't know either. And they said after the episode aired that they got mailed, that people were like, yeah, a rundown. Yeah, run down.
Like people had heard of it. And they were like, no way. So I looked it up. I googled, because we're ladies
at Google. We are. I just wrote, what is a rundown. And this is what the internet had to say.
Okay. In businesses, a rundown is a status report or summary. Yeah. I mean, common sense would
我知道。所以当我们联系吉恩和李时，他们说整个工作总结的故事是后来加进去的。这是重写环节的一部分。你知道，我们谈过有些编剧会分成小组。所以保罗·利伯斯坦、詹·萨拉塔和B.J.诺瓦克脱离了小组。在大约两个小时内，他们想出了整个工作总结的剧情。我喜欢这个。我知道。然后贾斯汀·斯皮策说，他们觉得这很棒。这种工作总结是一个模糊的术语。编剧室里没人真正知道它是什么意思。所以他们想，嗯，那太完美了。也许吉姆也不会知道。他们说剧集播出后，他们收到了邮件，人们说，是的，工作总结。是的，总结。好像人们都听说过一样。他们当时就想，没门。所以我查了一下。我用谷歌搜了，因为我们是谷歌女孩。我们是。我只是写了，什么是工作总结。这就是互联网给出的答案。好的。在商业中，工作总结是一份状态报告或摘要。是的。我的意思是，常识会
lead me in that direction. If I had to guess, I would think, oh, I should make a list of all my current
clients and their status. Yeah, I think I could have been a little confused. Like, is the rundown
my sales? Is it like an itemized thing of how much product I move? Or is it more just my client's
names and how long they've been in my clients? You know, I think there is a little bit of vagueness,
like Justin said. But Jim just needs to ask, what do you want to run down of? My clients? The inventory?
What exactly? Sales. Sales? Well, I'll tell you what, we got a lot of mail on this in
Hannah Q had a strong opinion.
Oh.
引导我往那个方向想。如果让我猜，我会想，哦，我应该列出我所有当前的客户及其状态。是的，我想我可能会有点困惑。工作总结是我的销售额吗？它是某种我卖出多少产品的明细表吗？还是仅仅是我的客户名单以及他们成为我客户的时间？你知道，我觉得确实有一点模糊，就像贾斯汀说的那样。但吉姆只需要问，你想要什么的总结？我的客户？库存？具体是什么？销售额。销售额？好吧，我告诉你，我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件，汉娜·Q有强烈的观点。哦。
Saying, forgive me for saying this, but I think I'm on Charles' side when it comes to the rundown.
I've never had an office job.
And even I have a pretty clear idea of what it could or should look like.
Come on, Jim, you're a smart guy.
Look within and find the rundown.
Hannah's not having it.
She's not having it.
Meanwhile, in the kitchen, we're going to kick off this storyline where Dwight and Andy are both
她说，请原谅我这么说，但在工作总结这件事上，我站在查尔斯这边。我从来没做过办公室工作。即使是我，对它看起来应该是什么样子也有相当清晰的概念。拜托，吉姆，你是个聪明人。往内看，找到那个工作总结。汉娜不买账。她不买账。与此同时，在厨房里，我们要开启一段剧情，德怀特和安迪都在
kind of flirting with Aaron.
Dwight does this weird thing where he teases her about the office being haunted, and then
Andy comes in and they end up doing a little dance together.
It's going to get awkward real fast.
It really is.
What happened to their bromance?
It's already being tested.
I know.
以某种方式调戏艾琳。德怀特做了一件奇怪的事，他逗她说办公室闹鬼，然后安迪进来了，他们最后一起跳了一小段舞。这很快就会变得尴尬起来。确实会。他们的兄弟情怎么了？它已经受到考验了。我知道。
Jenna, you know, like when you make a personal call and you know you need to make a personal
call, but, you know, other people can overhear you.
So you try to practice some form of etiquette in that phone call.
Or speak in code a little bit.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. That's going to be happening at the Michael Scott Paper Company.
It sure is. And there is a joke right off the bat that was so funny to me where Ryan is making plans for the weekend. And then he says, yeah, she's like a New York six, but in Scranton, she's a seven. And then he says, and my boss is my old boss, which makes it very clear that the Scranton seven is Pam in New York six. And they cut to you.
And your face as you realize it is so great.
珍娜，你知道，当你打私人电话时，你知道你需要打私人电话，但你知道别人能听到。所以你会在电话里尝试某种礼仪。或者用一点暗语。嗯哼。是的，这会在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司发生。确实会。而且一开始就有一个笑话让我觉得特别好笑，瑞恩在计划周末。然后他说，是的，她就像纽约的6分，但在斯克兰顿，她是7分。然后他说，而且我的老板是我以前的老板，这清楚地表明斯克兰顿的7分是帕姆，纽约的6分是帕姆。镜头切到你。你意识到这一点时的表情太棒了。
Justin said he felt like this was one of those amazing moments where the joke came before the setup.
Yes.
And paid off in this amazing way.
The whole thing is such a smart joke.
It's so well crafted.
It made me laugh.
I absolutely loved it.
So I think we should stay down here in Michael Scott Paper Company and discuss the next thing that's going to happen,
贾斯汀说他觉得这是那些精彩时刻之一，笑话先于铺垫出现。是的。并以这种惊人的方式得到了回报。整件事是一个非常聪明的笑话。它制作得太好了。它让我笑了。我绝对喜欢它。所以我认为我们应该留在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，讨论接下来要发生的事情，
which is Ryan watching a video online instead of making the copies that Michael has requested.
Yes.
At seven minutes, seven seconds, you can see the video that Ryan is watching. It was actually a local
commercial in Alabama that became very popular on YouTube, and I want to tell you a little bit about it.
So this went viral in 2006. A man named Sammy Stevens created and wrote and performed a jingle
for his Montgomery Alabama business. It was a flea market. Oh, yeah. And he did his own commercial.
And it went viral.
Over 12 million people have watched this video.
那就是瑞恩在网上看视频，而不是去复印迈克尔要求的文件。是的。在7分07秒，你可以看到瑞恩正在看的视频。那实际上是阿拉巴马州的一个当地广告，在YouTube上变得非常流行，我想告诉你一点关于它的事。这在2006年走红。一个叫萨米·史蒂文斯的人为他在阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利的生意创作、编写并演唱了一首广告歌。那是一个跳蚤市场。哦，是的。他自己拍了广告。它走红了。超过1200万人观看了这个视频。
Of course, it went viral before YouTube was kind of YouTube, right?
And it wasn't monetized.
So he has said in interviews, he didn't make any money off that.
But it really took off.
And Ellen DeGeneres had him on as a guest.
Really?
Uh-huh.
The flea market is no longer in business.
当然，它在YouTube成为YouTube之前就走红了，对吧？而且它没有变现。所以他在采访中说，他没从那上面赚到钱。但它确实火了。艾伦·德杰尼勒斯还请他做过嘉宾。真的吗？嗯哼。那个跳蚤市场现在已经倒闭了。
But Sammy is still writing commercial campaigns and performing.
He has appearances on TV and a radio show.
And I found Sammy on Instagram.
He's at the real Sammy Stevens, S-T-E-P-H-E-N-S.
Something I love about our show is that we were always working in these pop culture topical moments
because that's what people do.
That's what you would do is watch this YouTube video that was very popular while you were at work.
It makes total sense to me.
但萨米仍然在写商业广告并进行表演。他有电视和广播节目的出镜机会。我在Instagram上找到了萨米。他是@therealsammystevens，S-T-E-P-H-E-N-S。我喜欢我们节目的一点是，我们总是把这些流行文化的热点时刻融入其中，因为人们就是这样。你会做的事就是在工作时看这个非常流行的YouTube视频。这对我来说完全说得通。
Yeah, and you would show all your coworkers.
It's actually something that would happen on our set.
As we've shared, Oscar had the only working computer with sound, and we would all huddle
around his computer and watch videos.
Well, at seven minutes and five seconds, at the very top of this scene, you can see something
sitting next to Ryan in the little, like, poker chip.
Caddy?
Yeah, because we're sitting at a poker table, which is amazing.
是的，你会给所有同事看。这实际上是我们片场会发生的事情。正如我们分享的那样，奥斯卡有唯一一台带声音的电脑，我们都会挤在他的电脑周围看视频。好吧，在7分05秒，在这一幕的最开始，你可以看到瑞恩旁边放着一个东西，像是一个扑克筹码盒？是的，因为我们坐在扑克桌旁，这太棒了。
It is an inhaler.
Yes.
This was a whole deleted runner.
That Ryan uses an inhaler.
And he and Pam even get in a fight at one point.
she steals his inhaler. Well, because Michael, he hands it to Michael for Michael to use. And she's like,
wait, that might be bad for him. Yeah. It's a whole thing. It ended up getting cut. But that's why
那是一个吸入器。是的。这是一个完整的删减情节。是的。瑞恩使用吸入器。他和帕姆甚至在某个时候吵了一架。她偷了他的吸入器。好吧，因为迈克尔，他把它递给迈克尔让迈克尔用。然后她说，等等，那对他可能不好。是的。这是一整件事。最后被剪掉了。但这就是为什么
there is this inhaler and you can spot it throughout the episode sitting next to the laptop.
There is also a fantastic shot at seven minutes, 36 seconds of all the clocks on the wall.
Mm-hmm. I think we have to talk about them. There is a clock for Paris, London, Beijing, and the
USA. According to Gene and Lee and Justin, the USA clock was set to Scranton, but all the other
clocks were set to the time interval between those cities and Los Angeles. And they caught this
error halfway through the episode and they were just like, ah, we can't change it now. We have to
just leave it. Oh, we got a lot of mail about those clocks, Angela. I'm very glad that you brought
it up. People will feel very satisfied because that has been spotted. You know, also in this scene,
会有这个吸入器，你可以在整集中看到它放在笔记本电脑旁边。在7分36秒还有一个精彩的镜头，展示了墙上所有的时钟。嗯哼。我觉得我们得谈谈它们。有一个巴黎、伦敦、北京和美国的时钟。根据吉恩、李和贾斯汀的说法，美国时钟被设置为斯克兰顿时间，但所有其他时钟被设置为这些城市与洛杉矶之间的时间差。他们在剧集进行到一半时发现了这个错误，他们当时就想，啊，我们现在改不了了。我们只能留着它。哦，我们收到了很多关于那些时钟的邮件，安吉拉。我很高兴你提到了它。人们会感到非常满足，因为那个错误被发现了。你知道，在这一幕里，
there is this very subtle thing that happens between Ryan and Pam that makes me laugh.
They're discussing who should make the copies. And Ryan says, you're just so good at it.
You should do it, Pam. And she's like, you're saying that what I'm good at is pressing a big green button.
And he's kind of like, listen, I don't judge what we're good at. Yeah, he's like, why is it insulting to say that you're good at something?
Yeah. So this reminded me.
of this very funny back and forth that my husband and I have had because I always say that Lee
makes the best coffee in the morning and the best eggs. And I guess I'm very complimentary about it.
I'm always like, these are the best eggs. This is the best coffee. So about like five years into our
瑞恩和帕姆之间发生了一件非常微妙的事情，让我发笑。他们在讨论谁应该去复印。瑞恩说，你太擅长这个了。你应该去做，帕姆。她说，你是说我擅长的是按一个大绿按钮。他就像是，听着，我不评判我们擅长什么。是的，他就像是，说你擅长某事为什么是侮辱？是的。所以这让我想起了我和我丈夫之间非常有趣的来回对话，因为我总是说李早上做的咖啡最好，鸡蛋也做得最好。我想我对此非常赞美。我总是说，这是最好的鸡蛋。这是最好的咖啡。所以大约在我们结婚五年后，
marriage, Lee says to me, do I really make the best eggs?
Five years.
Yeah.
He's been holding on to that.
He says, do I really make the best coffee and the best eggs?
Or is it just that you don't want to make them?
And I was like, what?
And he said, I mean, how hard is it to make good coffee and eggs, really?
李对我说，我真的做得出最好的鸡蛋吗？五年了。是的。他一直记着这个。他说，我真的做得出最好的咖啡和最好的鸡蛋吗？还是说你只是不想做？我说，什么？他说，我的意思是，做好的咖啡和鸡蛋真的很难吗？
Oh, no.
I feel like maybe you're just complimenting my coffee and eggs so that I make you coffee
and eggs every day. And I was like, no, they really are superior. I swear, it's better coffee than I make.
I mean, that we could prove because there were some mornings when I made the coffee. And Lee was like,
oh, yeah, it's not great. But Lee doesn't eat eggs. I eat eggs in the morning. And he would always
make me my eggs. But it's the truth, babe. Lee, you make the best coffee and eggs. You just do.
Lee, I've traveled only a handful of times with your wife. I know you have traveled with her many, many times. And I know that this woman does not lie about food or beverage.
Thank you. She is completely earnest when she likes something and when she doesn't, you're going to know about it.
哦，不。我觉得也许你只是在夸我的咖啡和鸡蛋，这样我就能每天为你做咖啡和鸡蛋了。我说，不，它们确实是顶级的。我发誓，这比我做的咖啡好。我的意思是，我们可以证明，因为有些早上是我做的咖啡。李就会说，哦，是的，不太好。但李不吃鸡蛋。我早上吃鸡蛋。他总是会为我做鸡蛋。但这是事实，宝贝。李，你做的咖啡和鸡蛋就是最好的。你就是做得好。李，我和你妻子一起旅行过几次。我知道你和她一起旅行过很多很多次。而且我知道这个女人在食物或饮料上从不撒谎。谢谢。她喜欢什么东西时是非常真诚的，如果不喜欢，你一定会知道的。
That's the thing. I'm not going to eat mediocre eggs for five years just because someone else made them for me. I mean, if I really believed I could make better eggs, I'd be making my own eggs.
Oh, yeah. Well, once again, while people are talking in Michael Scott Paper Company, you hear someone in the bathroom.
Yeah, you hear their voice through the ceiling. You hear them peeing. We had a fan question from Afrin R in the scene where Michael, Pam, and Ryan are in their small new office and we hear a male voice talking on his phone in the bathroom. Whose voice is it? It sounds like Toby, but the conversation made me doubt it. It was Toby.
did the voice. Now, on the commentary, I think Gene and Lee joked that they made Paul sit up in the
ceiling tiles to do his lines. But that is not true. He was actually just off camera. He was not in the
ceiling. They added all the effects in post to make it sound like he was in the bathroom above us,
including like all the peeing sounds. But it really sounds like he's above you. I mean,
I was so sold on that. Yeah. No, he was not. He was just off camera. But incidentally, I would like
就是这样。我不会为了别人给我做饭就吃五年的平庸鸡蛋。我的意思是，如果我真的相信我能做出更好的鸡蛋，我会自己做。哦，是的。好吧，当人们在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司交谈时，你会听到浴室里有人。是的，你通过天花板听到了他们的声音。你听到他们在撒尿。我们收到了来自Afrin R的粉丝提问，在迈克尔、帕姆和瑞恩在他们狭小的新办公室的那一幕里，我们听到一个男声在浴室里打电话。那是谁的声音？听起来像托比，但谈话内容让我怀疑。是托比。配了音。现在，在评论音轨里，我想吉恩和李开玩笑说他们让保罗坐在天花板瓷砖上说他的台词。但那不是真的。他实际上只是在镜头外。他不在天花板里。他们在后期添加了所有效果，让它听起来像他在我们上面的浴室里，包括所有的撒尿声。但这听起来真的像他在你上面。我的意思是，我完全相信了。是的。不，他没有。他只是在镜头外。但顺便说一句，我想
to point out that our sound team was nominated for an Emmy for outstanding sound mixing for a comedy
or drama series half hour for this episode. Well, they deserve it. I know. They really sounded like
he was up there. And all the flushing and everything. Well, Michael's going to call his mom and talk in
code, Jenna, much in the way that you and I talk in code. He's really bad at it. It's so obvious.
So obvious. He says, Mom, they're getting on my nerves. Our thinks he's too good to be here. And P is not as much
fun without Jim. And then he's like, Mom, I got to go. P's being a giant B. This is us, lady.
Well, this whole thing is going to end with Pam and Ryan bickering over the computer. I mean,
they get in a huge fight over who gets to use it. And at eight minutes and 20 seconds,
指出我们的音效团队因这一集的半小时喜剧或剧情类剧集杰出音效混音获得了艾美奖提名。好吧，他们当之无愧。我知道。听起来真的像他在上面。还有所有的冲水声等等。好吧，迈克尔要给他妈妈打电话并用暗语交谈，珍娜，就像你和我用暗语交谈一样。他真的很不擅长。太明显了。太明显了。他说，妈，他们让我很烦。R觉得他太好了，不该待在这里。没有吉姆，P就没那么有趣了。然后他说，妈，我得挂了。P是个大混蛋。这就是我们，女士。好吧，整件事将以帕姆和瑞恩为电脑争吵而结束。我的意思是，他们为谁能用电脑大吵了一架。在8分20秒，
at the end of this scene, the camera pushes in on Michael. He's standing in front of the whiteboard.
And written on the whiteboard is a quote that says,
you miss 100% of the shots you don't take.
Wayne Gretzky, Michael Scott.
As if Wayne Gretzky is part of the quote.
Yes.
Right?
Michael Scott is quoting himself, quoting Wayne Gretzky.
在这一幕结束时，镜头推向迈克尔。他站在白板前。白板上写着一句名言：你错过了100%你不去尝试的投篮。韦恩·格雷茨基，迈克尔·斯科特。好像韦恩·格雷茨基是引语的一部分。是的。对吧？迈克尔·斯科特在引用他自己，引用韦恩·格雷茨基。
Justin Spitzer wrote that joke.
Gene and Lee both brought it up saying it was one of their favorite parts of the episode.
Like, I see that meme all the time.
Oh, yeah.
It's so brilliant.
If you Google,
Gretzky's quote, a Michael Scott version with his picture comes up. It's crazy. Well, why don't we take a break?
And when we come back, we still have to discuss the pancake luncheon and Dwight and Andy's rivalry and Jim maybe finally figuring out what a rundown is.
贾斯汀·斯皮策写了这个笑话。吉恩和李都提到了它，说这是他们最喜欢的剧集片段之一。就像，我经常看到那个梗。哦，是的。太天才了。如果你谷歌搜索格雷茨基的名言，会出现一张迈克尔·斯科特版本的图片。太疯狂了。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下？回来后，我们还要讨论煎饼午餐、德怀特和安迪的竞争，以及吉姆可能终于弄清楚了什么是工作总结。
And also a scene where maybe Jim has disappeared. Where has he gone? You might have the answer.
Oh, wow. Oh, I also have a sunglasses.
thing. Oh, and I do too. There's so much to come back for. We're back. Dwight is going to
approach Andy about his obvious attraction to Aaron and only a way that Dwight would about
tingly feelings and blood flow to places. Yes, but he also confesses that he has his own feelings for
Aaron. Mm-hmm. And they sort of talk about like, no, no, no, I don't want to get in your way and vice versa.
I want you to note at 9 minutes, 28 seconds, while Dwight and Andy are talking,
Erin is in the background directly in the middle of these two guys.
还有一幕是吉姆可能消失了。他去哪儿了？你可能有答案。哦，哇。哦，我还有一副太阳镜。事情。哦，我也有。还有很多内容要回来讨论。我们回来了。德怀特要就安迪对艾琳明显的吸引力与他交谈，方式只有德怀特才会用，谈论刺痛感和血液流向某些地方。是的，但他还承认他对艾琳也有自己的感觉。嗯哼。他们谈论着，不，不，不，我不想挡你的路，反之亦然。我想请你注意在9分28秒，当德怀特和安迪交谈时，艾琳在背景中，正好在这两个家伙中间。
Oh, I'm sure that was on purpose.
Oh, it was.
Jean and Lee said that was intentional.
They said they did this as many times as they could in this episode,
because it is a story about a woman coming between two guys.
I really loved Leslie's look in the background as well.
Well, there's a lot to see in the background of the scene. That's pretty great.
And there's also someone missing in the background of this scene.
哦，我肯定那是故意的。哦，是的。吉恩和李说那是故意的。他们说他们在这一集中尽可能多地这样做，因为这是一个关于一个女人介入两个男人之间的故事。我也非常喜欢莱斯利在背景中的表情。好吧，这一幕的背景里有很多东西可以看。那真的很棒。而且这一幕的背景里还有一个人不见了。
Where is Jim?
Hmm. I can tell you where he was.
Where was he?
They shared in the commentary that John had to leave early to be on the Tonight Show.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, you know, we were rapidly approaching our 100th episode of the office, which is going to be company picnic, the finale of season five.
And we were starting to do a lot of press and promotion for that.
I saw on the call sheets that after work on Thursday of this week, me and John and Rain stayed after work and we shot some syndicated promos.
吉姆在哪里？嗯。我可以告诉你他在哪里。他在哪里？他们在评论音轨中分享说，约翰必须提前离开去参加《今夜秀》。哦，天哪。好吧，你知道，我们正在迅速接近我们的第100集《办公室》，也就是公司野餐，第五季的结局。我们开始为那集做大量的媒体宣传和推广。我在通告单上看到，本周四下班后，我和约翰还有雷恩留下来拍摄了一些联合推广短片。
Oh, yeah.
I found some old emails that a few of us did a satellite media tour as well.
I bet.
Yeah.
I always got roped in for those and they started at four in the morning because you do East Coast to West Coast.
We were very excited.
We were happy to do it.
We were team players. I was always really proud of our group effort for the show.
哦，是的。我发现了一些旧邮件，我们几个人也做过卫星媒体巡回宣传。我敢打赌。是的。我总是被拉去参加那些活动，而且它们从凌晨四点就开始了，因为你要从东海岸一直做到西海岸。我们当时非常兴奋。我们很乐意去做。我们是团队合作者。我一直为我们团队为这部剧所做的努力感到非常自豪。
Well, Jim is going to reappear pretty quickly because he's asking Oscar what the rundown is, right?
Mm-hmm. He's gone over to the accounting nook much in the way that Michael used to do.
He would go ask Oscar what something meant. And now Jim is doing it.
I mean, Oscar's kind of the smartest guy in the office.
Jenna, I love that you said that because Justin Spitzer said this in the commentary.
He joked that Oscar was the voice of the writers.
He's the smartest guy who's always judging everyone.
Yeah, 100%.
嗯，吉姆很快就会再次出现，因为他在问奥斯卡“工作进度表”是什么，对吧？嗯。他走到会计角落，就像迈克尔过去常做的那样。他会去问奥斯卡某件事是什么意思。现在吉姆也在做同样的事。我的意思是，奥斯卡算是办公室里最聪明的人。珍娜，我很高兴你这么说，因为贾斯汀·斯皮策在评论中也提到了这一点。他开玩笑说奥斯卡是编剧们的代言人。他是那个总是评判每个人的最聪明的人。是的，百分之百。
But Oscar says, why don't you just ask him?
Just ask Charles what the rundown is.
So there was a deleted scene where Jim actually took Oscar's advice.
What?
Yeah, you've got to hear it.
You have a second?
What is it, Jim?
It's about the rundown.
但奥斯卡说，你为什么不直接问他呢？直接问查尔斯“工作进度表”是什么。所以有一个被删减的片段，吉姆实际上听取了奥斯卡的建议。什么？是的，你一定要听听。你有空吗？怎么了，吉姆？是关于工作进度表的事。
Jim, God, this rundown.
is taking more of my time than if I did it myself.
What?
What is the question now?
What's a rundown?
Is this one of your pranks?
Huh?
Yep.
吉姆，天哪，这个工作进度表花了我比我自己做还要多的时间。什么？现在又有什么问题？什么是工作进度表？这是你的恶作剧之一吗？哈？是的。
Boom.
Jim.
Sorry.
I don't have time.
I know.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to get you that rundown.
砰。吉姆。抱歉。我没时间。我知道。好吧。好的。我会给你那个工作进度表的。
Just get it to you, Jim.
Right now.
I'm going to go out and find it.
Oh my gosh.
Isn't that amazing?
And I love that Charles clearly knows that Jim's the prankster,
which he probably, you know, just add that to the list of things he doesn't like about Jim.
But Jim actually asked him and then bailed.
这就给你，吉姆。现在就去。我要出去把它找出来。天哪。这不是很神奇吗？我喜欢查尔斯清楚地知道吉姆是个恶作剧者，他可能，你知道，只是把这一点加到他不喜欢的吉姆的清单里。但吉姆真的问了他，然后就溜了。
I bet that was a really funny scene.
I wish that had stayed in.
It was great.
There was so much awkward, just long pauses.
Oh.
Well, back downstairs, Michael determines that their office space is too small.
He says that the solution is for Pam and Ryan to each choose a corner.
Pam suggests they work from home.
我敢打赌那一定是个非常有趣的场景。我真希望它能保留下来。那太棒了。有很多尴尬的、漫长的停顿。哦。好吧，回到楼下，迈克尔断定他们的办公空间太小了。他说解决方案是让帕姆和瑞安各自选一个角落。帕姆建议他们在家办公。
Ryan suggests Michael.
fire whichever of them has less education. There's a little bit of that passive aggressive.
But Michael is like, no, my corner idea is what it is. I want you to know there was a talking
head in the script where Michael says that he negotiated a seven-year lease on this space.
No. No. But it gets worse. He says originally Billy started at three years. Michael countered
with seven. No, Michael. And then Michael says,
They should have said 10.
Oh, gosh.
瑞安建议迈克尔解雇他们中受教育程度较低的那个人。这有点被动攻击的意思。但迈克尔却说，不，我的角落主意就是这样。我想让你知道，剧本里有一个迈克尔的独白，他说他为这个空间谈下了一份七年的租约。不。不。但更糟糕的是。他说最初比利提议的是三年。迈克尔还价七年。不，迈克尔。然后迈克尔说，他们本该说十年的。哦，天哪。
So this is going to be their space for seven years.
Oh, my gosh.
Justin pointed out something really funny.
He was like, you know, when Michael says, there are four corners in this room.
Yeah.
You guys kind of look to camera like, yeah, idiot.
Actually, there were more than four.
There were because there were some like weird bumpy things.
所以这将是他们未来七年的空间。哦，天哪。贾斯汀指出了一个非常有趣的地方。他说，你知道，当迈克尔说，这个房间有四个角落时。是的。你们看着镜头，好像在说，是的，白痴。实际上，角落不止四个。因为还有一些奇怪的凸起部分。
Yeah.
Well, Pam is going to retreat to her corner.
By the way, her corner is next to the sewage pipe and the shower.
Facing a wall.
You think it can't get worse.
Ryan's corner is like behind a plant.
It's actually kind of the nicest corner, really.
But things are going to get worse for Pam because Michael says that's his corner because he can't work in the same corner that he relaxes in.
是的。好吧，帕姆要退到她的角落里去了。顺便说一句，她的角落就在污水管和淋浴间旁边。面对着一堵墙。你以为情况不会更糟了。瑞安的角落就像是在一株植物后面。实际上那算是最好的角落了，真的。但帕姆的情况会变得更糟，因为迈克尔说那是他的角落，因为他不能在他放松的同一个角落里工作。
Right.
So she's like, which one's mine?
And he says yours is the one over there.
Buy the copier.
Oh.
We had a fan catch at 12 minutes one second.
And it's a great continuity catch.
It's very subtle.
对。所以她说，哪一个是我的？他说你的是那边那个。在复印机旁边。哦。我们在12分01秒处有一个粉丝发现的细节。这是一个很棒的连续性发现。非常微妙。
So hats off to Tatiana V.
Who says,
When Pam goes to sit in her corner,
she takes a small black object with her.
You can see her holding it in her lap as the camera swings back and forth from her and Michael.
But right before she gets up to leave,
it has disappeared from her hands because Pam is,
is now holding the arms of her chair.
所以向塔蒂亚娜·V致敬。她说，当帕姆去坐在她的角落里时，她带了一个黑色的小物件。当镜头在帕姆和迈克尔之间来回切换时，你可以看到她把它抱在怀里。但在她起身离开之前，它从她手中消失了，因为帕姆现在正抓着椅子的扶手。
What is it?
That's what she wanted to know.
It was Pam's flip phone.
Pam grabs her flip phone off of the poker table,
but clearly I didn't do it in every take
because it does just vanish.
I miss my flip phone.
You do?
那是什么？这就是她想知道的。那是帕姆的翻盖手机。帕姆从扑克桌上抓起她的翻盖手机，但显然我并不是在每次拍摄时都这么做，因为它确实消失了。我想念我的翻盖手机。你真的想念吗？
I do.
And I missed the little antenna it had
and how I would close the antenna with my chin.
I'd like shove it into my chin.
It did feel fun.
I loved it.
Yeah.
Well, you know, Sam,
我想念。我还想念它那个小天线，以及我如何用下巴合上天线。我会把它推到下巴里。那感觉确实很有趣。我喜欢它。是的。嗯，你知道，萨姆，
Samsung has a new flip phone thing.
Or you flip it open and it becomes like a big screen.
Have you seen the commercials for it?
I'll never be able to figure it out.
It's too many moving parts.
I know, but it looks cool in the commercials.
It really does, Samsung.
You know what I don't miss about my flip phone, lady.
三星有一款新的翻盖手机。或者你把它翻开，它就像一个大屏幕。你看过它的广告吗？我永远也搞不懂它。它有太多的活动部件。我知道，但在广告里看起来很酷。确实很酷，三星。你知道我不怀念我的翻盖手机什么吗，女士。
What?
I don't miss the texting where you had to play.
A, A, B, C, C, D, E, E, like you had to click, click.
Yeah.
Listen, all of this business with Ryan and the corners.
Pam's going to leave. She goes upstairs and she asks Charles for her old job back.
She doesn't consult her fiance. Not that she needs to consult him, but you know what I mean?
You would think she'd loop him in. You'd think she'd like say, Jim, I'm going to ask for my job back.
什么？我不怀念那种必须玩A、A、B、C、C、D、E、E的短信输入方式，就像你必须点点点一样。是的。听着，所有关于瑞安和角落的事情。帕姆要离开了。她上楼去问查尔斯能不能要回她原来的工作。她没有咨询她的未婚夫。并不是说她需要咨询他，但你知道我的意思吗？你会以为她会让他知道。你会以为她会说，吉姆，我要去要回我的工作了。
No. But she didn't consult him when she quit and she's not going to consult him now.
She's desperate. She doesn't have time for that conversation. No. Well, Charles says the position has been filled.
She says maybe a sales job. Maybe a job is his personal assistant.
personal shopper? Nope. No dice. So Justin talked about several different alts in the scene
where they had Charles be really sort of abrupt with Pam. And they dialed it back because it seemed
too harsh. So he's just more indifferent. He's just more business. Yeah. Well, this was my only
real one-on-one scene with Idris, except for when he sort of came in the first day. But that
wasn't much of an exchange. I was so nervous. I was such a fan. And to be standing there with this
不。但她辞职时没有咨询他，现在她也不会咨询他。她绝望了。她没有时间进行那种谈话。不。嗯，查尔斯说职位已经填满了。她说也许是销售工作。也许是做他的私人助理？私人购物员？不行。没门。所以贾斯汀谈到了这个场景中的几个不同的替代方案，他们让查尔斯对帕姆表现得非常生硬。但他们把它调低了，因为它看起来太严厉了。所以他只是更冷漠。他只是更公事公办。是的。嗯，这是我与伊德里斯唯一真正的对手戏，除了他第一天来的时候。但那并没有太多的交流。我太紧张了。我是他的超级粉丝。能和这位我非常钦佩的演员站在一起，因为我是《火线》的忠实粉丝。他在戏里有一种耐心、安静的力量。他真是个专业人士。我的意思是，我只是，我想我作为帕姆的一些紧张感，只是我作为珍娜与这位我钦佩的人表演时的紧张感。是的。关于迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司在楼下的消息显然已经传开了，因为菲利斯和斯坦利决定去顺便打个招呼。我们真的知道那是什么。他们只是在窥探。哦，是的。是的。我也会做同样的事。你在开玩笑吗？嗯，在场景开始时，当菲利斯和斯坦利探头进来时，我想让你注意迈克尔正在玩那个订书机。那个我们都喜欢的订书机，我们谁都爱不释手。我们会在她的桌子上认真地装订文件。
actor that I admired so much, because I was a huge fan of the wire. And he has such a patient,
quiet power in his scenes. And he's such a pro. I mean, I was just, I think some of my nervousness
as Pam was just my nervousness as Jenna performing with this person that I admired.
Yeah. Word has clearly gotten out about the Michael Scott Paper Company being downstairs because Phyllis and Stanley decided to go, pop by and say hi. We really know what it was. They were just snooping.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. I would do the same thing. Are you kidding?
Well, at the top of the scene, when Phyllis and Stanley poked their head in, I want you to notice that Michael is playing with the stapler.
The stapler that we loved, that none of us could keep our hands off of. We would see.
seriously staple papers on her desk.
所以你认为史蒂夫只是在玩他觉得很酷的订书机吗？因为我不知道该怎么解释这个订书机的气压机制。好吧，下次我去你家的时候。你能给我展示一下那个订书机吗？我真的应该把它带过来，因为你可以听到它的声音。就像是，咔嚓咔嚓咔嚓。就像在你的手掌中拥有工业订书机的所有力量。你应该为它们拍广告。我真的应该。
So do you think Steve was just like playing with the stapler he thought was cool?
Because I don't know how to explain this air pressure mechanism of the stapler.
Okay, next time I'm over at your house. Will you just show me the stapler?
I seriously should have brought it in because you can hear it.
It's like, k-ch-ch-ch-k-ch-wow.
It's like having all the power of an industrial stapler with the palm of your hand.
You should do commercials for them.
I really should.
他们应该赞助我们。只需手指一按。当你这样做时，它是一个工程奇迹，你会想把视线内的一切都订起来。天哪。我需要看看那个订书机。也许我应该拍一段自己订东西的视频，你可以把它放在办公室里。我会的。我会的。把它给我。我们都需要看看它。好的。我会做的。我需要把它拿在手里。我需要摸摸它。等一下。等一下。那正是她说的。我开始往那个方向说的那一刻。我就想，不，贝卡，啦啦啦。哇。
They should sponsor it.
us. It's just the push of your finger. And when you do it, it's such an engineering marvel that you
just want to staple everything in sight. Well, good Lord. I need to see the stapler. Maybe I should do
a video of myself stapling things and you can put it in the office. I will. I will. Give it to me.
We all need to see it. Okay. I'll do it. I need to hold it in my hand. I need to touch it.
Wait a second. Wait a second. That is what she said. The minute I started going down that road. I was like,
No, Becca, blah, la la.
Wow.
继续前进，女士，是时候开始这个煎饼午餐会了。迈克尔在外面。他正在为还没到的人做方形煎饼。瑞安在发短信。我喜欢迈克尔说，别再用那个发短信的机器了。嗯。所以我们到了，珍娜，在14分59秒处，我们第二副太阳镜出现了。哦，是的。
Moving us along, lady, it is time to kick off this pancake luncheon.
Michael is outside.
He is making square pancakes for nobody yet.
Ryan is texting.
I love that Michael's like, stop with the texting machine.
Mm-hmm.
So here we are, Jenna, at our second pair of sunglasses at 14 minutes, 59 seconds.
Oh, yes.
我有同样的时间码。你想对这些太阳镜说什么？等等，我们能同时说出来吗？虽然会很乱，但让我们看看听起来是否一样。好的。这些太阳镜的灵感来自于华金·菲尼克斯在大卫·莱特曼秀上的亮相。2009年，当他在宣传《我仍在这里》时。那是一次非常奇怪的亮相。
I have the same time code.
what do you want to say about these sunglasses?
Wait, can we say it right at the same time?
It'll be jarbled, but let's see if it sounds the same.
Okay.
These sunglasses were inspired by Joaquin Phoenix's appearance on the David Letterman Show.
In 2009, when he was promoting, I'm still here.
It was a very odd appearance.
我实时观看了那个节目。但这都是某种营销策略的一部分。他拍了这部电影。我想他是想让我们相信他真的转行了。这有点像安迪·考夫曼式的风格。我截了图。我为你做了一个对比图，女士。哦，发给我。
I watched that in real time.
But it was all part of like a marketing ploy or something.
He did this film.
And I guess he was trying to make us believe that he had actually switched careers.
And it was sort of like an Andy Kaufman-esque thing.
I took a screen grab.
I did a side-by-side for you, lady.
Oh, get to me.
菲尼克斯和瑞安，戴着同样的太阳镜。把它发到故事里。它们的零售价大约是400美元。什么？太阳镜要400美元？是的。你疯了吗？它们是处方镜吗？
Phoenix and Ryan, same sunglasses.
Putting that in stories.
They retail for about $400.
What?
For sunglasses?
Yeah.
Are you crazy?
Are they prescription?
不，它们只是时髦而已。那太疯狂了。我的意思是，如果我买了那副太阳镜，我还不如直接把400美元冲进马桶，因为我不到一年就会弄丢它们。我知道有些人喜欢时髦的太阳镜。听着，你做你自己就好，但我不知道，三个孩子，太阳镜，足球比赛，我的总是被弄坏。我花200美元买了一副处方太阳镜。我必须戴处方太阳镜。因为我戴双层眼镜太久了，你知道，就是你买一副巨大的普通太阳镜戴在你的真眼镜外面。我看到了，珍娜。你看上去就像需要住在佛罗里达的退休社区一样。我知道。而且你知道吗？我设法保留了那些处方太阳镜将近两年。我把它们弄丢在某个地方了。现在我又回到了双层眼镜。你知道我们需要什么吗？什么？乔希说我需要给眼镜配条链子。我有一个关于我妈妈的故事。发生了什么？就是这样，对吧？就是这样。你的性感日子结束了。如果你把眼镜挂在链子上？我不知道。嗯，我妈妈，我们亲切地叫她露西，因为当你和她一起走进商店时，就像和《我爱露西》里的露西尔·鲍尔一起购物，因为她总能被商店的陈列品缠住或撞倒它们。我正想说，她是撞倒东西还是试图往嘴里塞太多巧克力？所以我们和她一起购物，她戴着挂在那种链子上的眼镜。但那是冬天。所以她还戴着围巾。而且她还，我不知道为什么，戴着长项链，一个斜挎包。她去摘下她的斜挎包。它拉到了她的眼镜链。胳膊乱挥。她撞倒了一整排耳环陈列架。哦，不。我和我姐姐冲过去想帮她。她被缠住了。她看起来像一只被绳子缠住的猫，陈列架都在倒塌。所以每当我想把眼镜挂在链子上时，那个记忆就会浮现，我想那可能就是我。我可能就是那样。我很容易就会那样做。我可能会撞倒一个陈列架。你可能会撞倒一个陈列架。我看到你在飞机上差点用吉他撞到几个人。是的。是的。所以我的底线是不能给眼镜配链子。哦，好吧。我很抱歉。好的。但我们为瑞安这个角色花了400美元买这些眼镜，为了这个非常微妙的内部笑话，显然瑞安是华金·菲尼克斯的粉丝，可能看到了那个。这很符合角色。他就是那种必须拥有最新东西的人。尽管他妈妈开车送他去上班。是的，没错。他真的没有工作。就像，他没有赚工资。他没有。他要买400美元的太阳镜。在15分10秒，就在帕姆走过来的时候，有一个很棒的假杂货袋的镜头。哦，假袋子。我们有一些假袋子。珍娜，你在评论中分享了一些勾起我回忆的事情。
No, they're just.
just fancy. That's nuts. I mean, if I bought that pair of sunglasses, I might as well just flush
$400 down the toilet because I'm going to lose them less than a year. I know some people like fancy
sunglasses. And listen, you do you, but I don't know, three kids, sunglasses, soccer games,
mine just get wrecked. I splurged on a pair of $200 prescription sunglasses. I have to have
prescription sunglasses. Because I was doing the double glasses for so long, you know, where you buy a giant pair of
regular sunglasses that you put over your real glasses. I saw it, Jenna. You look like you need to live
in like a Florida retirement community. I know. And you know what? I managed to keep those prescription
它立刻把我带回了那一天。你分享说，当你在拍摄这个停车场场景时，狗仔队溜进了我们的片场。哦，天哪，我记得那个。是的。我们有一个家伙。所以伙计们，我们不在一个大场地。我们之前分享过。我们没有保安。你直接开车进去就行了。确实。在那天之后，我们在一个小棚子里雇了一个保安。是的。是的。这个狗仔队家伙显然盯上了我们，意识到你可以直接开车进入片场，直接进来就开始对着片场、停车场、从拖车里出来的演员拍照。他们拍到了一张史蒂夫从他拖车里出来的照片。我们花了一段时间才反应过来，哦，那个人是谁？哦，天哪。哦，等等，等等。我们不，没人认识那个家伙。我在评论里提到过为什么我们认为这发生了吗，终于，在五季之后？没有。
sunglasses for almost two years. I lost them somewhere. And now I'm back to double glasses.
You know what we need? What? Josh says I need the chain on my glasses. I have a story about my mom.
What happens? That's it, right? That's it. Your sexy days are over. If you put your
glasses on a chain? I don't know. Well, my mom, we affectionately call her Lucy because when you go into a
store with her, it's like you're shopping with Lucille Ball from I Love Lucy because she will manage to get
tangled in or knock over any store display. I was going to say, does she knock things over or try to put
too many chocolates in her mouth? So we were shopping with her and she had on her glasses around one of
those chains. But it was winter. So she also had a scarf. And she also had, I don't know why, like,
约翰开始和艾米丽·布朗特约会了。哦，不。是的。所以这在小报上很有趣。嗯。直到现在，我们中没有人做过任何小报感兴趣的事，基本上。没有。没有。所以我记得这个，因为当时我在和李约会。他和我也开始认真起来了。约翰开始和艾米丽约会。我们成了情侣朋友。你们确实是。你们会一起去参加活动。我们确实去了。关于他们俩正在约会的消息终于传开了。
long necklaces, a purse, you know, cross-bodied. She goes to take off her cross-body purse.
It yanks on her sunglasses chain. Elbows are flying. She takes down a whole display of earrings.
Oh, no. My sister and I are, like, rushing in to, like, help her. She's tangled. She looks like a cat.
tangled in string and just displays are falling down. So whenever I think about putting my glasses
on a chain, that memory comes back to me and I think that could be me. I could be that. I could
easily have done that. I could take down a display. You could take down a display. I saw you almost
take out a few people on an airplane with a guitar. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, so I can't chain my glasses is the
bottom line. Oh, well. I'm sorry. Okay. But we spent $400 on these glasses for the character of
我想这就是狗仔队出现的原因。也许吧。因为这就像是五年后突然发生的。哦，这个家伙想要照片。是的，没错。我们有狗仔队出现的另一次是在我们为吉姆和帕姆的婚礼进行外景拍摄时。哦，是的。嗯，那会是一个大的……那是剧中的一个大事件。但大部分时间，我们没有那种东西。我们没有。谢天谢地，我很高兴我们只是我们那个隐蔽的小工作室。我同意。我确实认为有一次，狗仔队拍到了我离开拖车时拿着空午餐盘的照片。那是最……那让我笑了一下。那简直是最不讨喜的照片。那太完美了。
Ryan for this very subtle inside joke that clearly Ryan is a Joaquin Phoenix fan and probably
saw that. It's in character. He is the kind of guy who has to have the thing, the latest thing.
Even though his mom is driving him to work. Yes, exactly. He's really not employed. Like,
he's not earning a paycheck. He isn't. He's going to get $400 sunglasses.
At 15 minutes, 10 seconds, right as Pam is walking up, there's a great shot of some faky grocery bags.
Ooh, faky bags.
We got some faky bags.
And Jenna, you shared on the commentary something that jogged my memory.
一个吃完午餐的人。我，我，这是几年后的事了，伙计们。就像剧集已经结束了，我在度假。我在一个海滩，我想玛丽亚·莎拉波娃也在那里。狗仔队显然是为她来的。但我就像配菜。所以他们拍了她的照片，然后顺便拍了几张我的。它最终出现在了一本小报杂志上。
It took me back immediately to this day.
You shared while you were filming this parking lot scene, the paparazzi snuck onto our set.
Oh my gosh, I remember that.
Yes.
we had a guy. So guys, we weren't on a big lot. We've shared that before. We didn't have security. You just drove in. You did. And after this day, we got a security guard in a little hut. Yeah. Yeah. This paparazzi guy clearly staked us out, realized you could just drive right on the set, came right on and just started clicking pictures of the set, the parking lot, actors coming out of their trailers. They got one of Steve coming out of his trailer. And it took us all a while to be like, oh, who's that guy?
Oh, my God. Oh, wait, wait. We don't, no one knows that guy.
Did I mention in the commentary why we think this happened, finally, after five seasons?
No.
我看到了我的照片。我就想，我该怎么给他们发感谢信？那是一张你在度假时拍的很好的照片吗？穿着泳衣。我就想，我应该感谢某人。我会说我们可以把这些照片放在我们的故事里，但这就像我拿着空餐盘在找东西，而你在墨西哥度假。我刚锻炼完。
John had started dating Emily Blunt.
Oh, no.
Yeah. So that was sort of tabloid-y interesting.
Mm-hmm.
Until now, none of us did anything of tabloid interest, basically.
No. No. So I remember this because I was dating Lee at the time. He and I were starting to get
serious. And John started dating Emily. And we became couple friends. You did. You guys would
like go and do things. We did. And the news finally broke that the two of them were dating one another.
我只是想卖给某人。谢谢。谢谢你为我拍到那个。好吧，既然我们谈到了这个话题，我就再讲一个轶事。我真的，真的从来没有被狗仔队拍到过。我现在也没有。事实上，有一次我出了车祸。我被追逐克里斯蒂娜·里奇的狗仔队追尾了。
And I think that's why the paparazzi showed up. Maybe so. Because it was just sort of what,
five years in out of nowhere. Oh, this guy wants pictures. Yes, exactly. The one other time we had
paparazzi show up was when we were shooting on location for Jim and Pam's wedding. Oh, yeah. Well, that would have been a big...
That was like a big show event within the show. But for the most part, we didn't have any of that stuff.
We didn't. Thankfully, I'm glad that we were just our little tucked away little studio. I agree. I do think at one point, the paparazzi got a shot of me leaving my trailer with like my empty lunch plate. And it is the most...
That made me like short laugh.
It is just like the most unflattering photo.
That is so perfect.
我不得不下车。是的。我们不得不交换所有的信息。那个家伙在整个交换过程中从来没有拍过我的照片。还有一次我和安迪·罗迪克和布鲁克林·戴克出去吃晚饭。没人拍你的照片。他们围住了他们，然后每个人都在拍他们的照片。有人说，嘿，你能帮我拿一下相机吗？我们在他们后面。是的。他们几乎就像是，你能从那个迷人情侣的照片里让开吗？你们两个真的搞砸了我们拍迷人情侣的照片。那确实是我们的故事。
Of a person who has finished their lunch.
I, I, this was years later, you guys.
Like the show had ended and I was vacationing.
And I was at a beach that I guess Maria Sharapova was at.
And the pop rotsie clearly showed up for her.
But I was like side dish.
So they got the photos of her and then they snapped a few of me.
And it ended up in a tabloid magazine.
即使我在被狗仔队拍照的人附近，也没人关心。太真实了。我很感激。是的，我也是。好吧。继续，吉姆已经完成了他的工作进度表，各位。大新闻。他把它呈给查尔斯。查尔斯甚至不想看它。查尔斯就像是，把它传真给分发名单上的每个人。他被吉姆烦透了，因为这花了他一整天。是的。去整理一份名单。吉姆再次感到尴尬，并试图编造这件事。就像，是的，我只是，你知道，只是想看看，你知道，你和我是不是同样的格式。所以，是的。而且现在吉姆甚至不确定分发名单是什么。我知道。吉姆以前做过他的工作吗？他一直在做什么？我想让你们知道一件事。吉姆传真他爸爸分发名单的镜头，是艾莉在办公室工作的第一天拍摄的第一件事。啊。那是她在通告单上的第一场戏。然后她那天拍摄的第二场戏是剧集开头的那场戏，她和凯莉走进查尔斯的办公室，她们决定叫她艾伦。那是两场很好的第一场戏。如果我在剧中的第一场戏只是坐在背景的桌子旁，我会非常感激。不说话。是的。只是感受一下房间。是的。好吧，我们要有一个客串明星警报。
And I saw the picture of me.
And I was like, how do I send them a thank you?
Was it a really good picture of you on vacation?
In my bathing suit.
And I was like, I should thank someone.
I would say that we could put these photos in our stories, but it's going to be like me
hunting out of my empty food plate and you vacationing in Mexico.
I had just been working out.
我们有，因为帕姆正在和一个潜在客户聊天。一个人来到了煎饼午餐会。他看起来有点兴趣，也许不是真的感兴趣，对迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司有点兴趣。你真的看不出来。嗯，帕姆身上没有名片，所以她要撕下一张纸条。她觉得这很有诗意，因为，你知道，他们卖纸。她正在给它加点花样。帕姆正在交谈的那个潜在客户叫帕特里克·洛萨索。他是吉恩和李的拳击教练。是的。我记得他们上过拳击课。他们真的很喜欢。是的。
I just want to sell someone.
Thank you.
Thanks for getting that for me.
Well, since we're on the subject, I will just give this one more anecdote.
I really, really did not get photographed by the paparazzi ever.
And I still don't.
In fact, one time I got in a car accident.
I was rear-ended by the paparazzi who were chasing Christina Ricci.
嗯，那在当时非常流行。现在也还算流行，但在那个时候非常盛行。我的意思是，人们都在买那些，那些袋子是什么？他们打的，圆柱形的袋子。嗯，显然，珍娜和我没有上过任何拳击课。我们在这个场景中也看到了克里德和梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思想要拿一堆额外的煎饼。你们抓住了这个吗？
And I had to get out of my car.
Yeah.
And we had to exchange all of our information.
the guy never took my picture in the whole exchange. And then another time I was out to dinner
with Andy Roddock and Brooklyn Decker. No one took your picture. They swarmed them and then
everyone was taking their picture. Someone said, hey, can you hold my camera? We're behind them.
Yeah. They were almost like, could you get out of the way of the picture of the beautiful people,
please? You're really, you two are messing up our shot of the glamour couple. That was truly our story.
她说，为了我的孩子。是的。一个孩子。为了我的孩子。她的一个孩子。我们收到了很多关于那个的邮件，安吉拉。显然，在其中一个网络剧集里，梅雷迪思解释了第二个孩子的谜团。
Even when I was in the proximity of people being photographed by the paparazzi, no one cared.
So true. I'm grateful. Yeah, me too. All right. Moving on, Jim has completed his rundown, everybody.
Huge news. He presents it to Charles. Charles doesn't even want to look at it. Charles is like, just faxed to everyone on the distribution list.
He is so annoyed with Jim that it took him all day. Yeah. To just come.
Composal list. And Jim, once again, is, like, embarrassed and tries to make up this thing. Like, yeah, I was just, you know, just going to see if, you know, you and I had the same format. So, yeah. And also now Jim is not even sure what the distribution list is. I know. Has Jim done his job before? What is he doing all the time? I want you guys to know something. The shot of Jim faxing his dad, the distribution list, was the very first thing that Ellie shot on her very first day of work on the office.
Aw. That was her first scene on the call sheet. And then the second scene that she shot that day was that scene from the very top of the show where her and Kelly go into Charles's office and they decide to name her Aaron.
Those are two good first scenes. I would be so grateful if my first scene on a show was me just sitting at the desk in the background.
Not speaking. Yes. Just getting a feel for the room. Yeah. Well, we are about to have a guest star alert.
我们得重看那些网络剧集。我们真的得看。我们应该拆解那些网络剧集。我们应该把它加到我们的重看清单里，那些网络剧集。绝对的。我们必须这样做。好的。我们会做的。我们会做的。嗯，显然，梅雷迪思说当她离婚时，她的前夫得到了那个好孩子。她得到了另一个。所以有两个孩子。
we are because Pam is chatting up a potential client. One person has come to the pancake luncheon. He seems
slightly interested, maybe not really interested, slightly interested in Michael Scott Paper Company.
You can't really tell. Well, Pam doesn't have a business card on her, so she's going to tear off a scrap of paper. She finds that poetic because, you know, they sell paper. She's putting a spin on it. That potential client that Pam is talking to is named Patrick Losasso.
And he was Jean and Lee's boxing trainer.
Yeah.
I remember them taking boxing classes.
They were really into it.
Yeah.
好的。我们有一个来自艾丽莎、瑞安和马德琳的粉丝问题。他们想知道，早午餐上的那些煎饼是真的吗？它们是真正的煎饼。不可能。菲尔·谢雇了一个食品造型师，她在仓库里架起了一堆烤盘，她做了所有那些方形煎饼。我以为它们是那种假泡沫煎饼。不，它们是真正的可食用煎饼。我会吃一个的。我喜欢煎饼。嗯，你知道，做方形煎饼非常难。是的。你必须有一个特殊的平底锅什么的吗？它真的就像迈克尔做的那样，你几乎有一个像饼干模具的东西，但它仍然非常难做。艾恩斯利，我们的助理制片人，她帮我们准备剧集，发给我一个关于为什么煎饼是圆的以及为什么把它们做成任何其他形状都如此困难的深度解析。我会和你分享。这是因为重力均匀地作用于流体。所以当一团面糊以直角撞击烤盘时，由于物理学家所说的圆柱对称性，它会被拉成一个圆形的对称形状。这意味着如果你绕着它的轴旋转它，它的形状不会改变。这就是圆柱对称性。除了上下之外的所有方向都是一样的。另外，我想科学上说的表面张力，不管那是什么，是物理学，有助于把它保持在一个完美的圆圈里。
Well, that was really popular at the time.
It's still kind of popular, but it had a huge flourish around this time.
I mean, people were getting those, what are those bags?
That they hit, cylinder bags.
Well, clearly, Jenna and I did not take any boxing classes.
We get to see Creed and Meredith in this scene as well.
and Meredith wants to take a bunch of extra pancakes.
And did you guys catch this?
我们应该做一个科学播客。显然。显然。我很擅长这个。那是什么？我想那是物理学？那是离心力吗？有一种拉力。
She said, for my kid.
Yeah.
One kid.
For my kid.
Her one kid.
We've received a lot of mail about that, Angela.
Apparently, in one of the webisodes,
Meredith explains the mystery of the second kid.
然后有一种，你知道吗，重力。我要回到重力。是的。这就是为什么煎饼是圆的某种原因，感谢mental floss和quora.com的一些文章。真的，这对我来说很迷人。我不知道怎么复述，我甚至不明白你说了什么，但我欣赏它背后的科学。当你做煎饼时，只要知道有很多物理学在起作用。是的。
We've got to rewatch the webisodes.
We really do.
We should break down the webisodes.
We should add it to our rewatch, the webisodes.
Absolutely.
We must do this.
Okay. We will do this. We will do this. Well, apparently, Meredith says that when she got divorced,
her ex-husband got the good kid. And she got the other one. So there are two kids.
我的意思是，听着，我想如果你记住了我说的话，下次你为你的孩子们做煎饼时，你只要把它抛出来，你听起来会很聪明。我会弄错的。他们会指出来的。你会像写在手上一样。我知道。或者写在卡片上。我需要一张可爱的卡片。这让我想到了。
Okay. We had a fan question from Alyssa, Ryan, and Madeline. They wanted to know, were those real
pancakes at the brunch? They were real pancakes. No way. Phil Shea hired a food stylist who had a bunch of
griddles set up in the warehouse, and she made all of those square pancakes. I thought they were
like faky foam pancakes. No, they were real edible pancakes. I would have eaten one. I love pancakes.
Well, you know, it is very hard to make a square pancake. Yeah. Do you have to have a special pan or
something? It's really like what Michael did, where you have almost like a cookie cutter thing,
but it is still incredibly difficult to do. Ainsley, our associate producer, who helps us prep our
episodes sent me a deep dive on why pancakes are round and why it is so difficult to make them any
哦。哦。真是太棒的场景了。安迪和德怀特在休息室。安迪在弹班卓琴。德怀特在弹吉他，他们正在即兴演奏《带我回家，乡村路》，艾伦在旁边看着，印象深刻。哦，是的，他们真的在试图在对方面前胜过对方。她跟着唱。
other shape. I will share with you. It is because gravity pulls on fluid uniformly. So when the
dollop of batter hits the griddle at a right angle, it gets tugged down into a round symmetrical
shape due to what physicists call cylindrical symmetry. This means that
that its shape will not change if you rotate it around its axis.
That is what cylindrical symmetry is.
All directions except up and down are the same.
Also, I guess the scientific thing that is surface tension, whatever that is, is the physics,
that helps hold it in a perfect circle.
嗯。太神奇了。我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝邮件。艾比·凯特想知道这其中是否有即兴创作，因为艾伦在他们开始唱歌时看起来真的很震惊。然后贾斯珀·D想知道，雷恩在现实生活中真的会弹吉他吗？还是他必须为了这个场景专门学习？嗯，首先，这一切都是计划好的。这一切都是写好的剧本。
We should do a science podcast.
Clearly.
I'm good at it.
What is that?
I think that's physics?
Is that the centrifugal?
There's a pulling.
事实上，兰迪·科德雷告诉我们，为这个场景授权这首歌花费了22,000美元。另外，雷恩确实会弹吉他。他还会打鼓。还有竖笛。还有竖笛，我们知道的。还有巴松管。哦，天哪。他会演奏很多乐器。
And then there's a, you know what, gravity.
I'm going to go back to gravity.
Yeah.
That is some reason why pancakes are round, thanks to some articles by mental floss and quora.com.
Truly, it is fascinating to me.
I don't know how to retell that, and I don't even understand what you said, but I appreciate the science behind it.
When you make a pancake, just know there's a lot of physics at work.
Yeah.
他还会杂耍。他是个很棒的杂耍演员。他就像个文艺复兴时期的人。他确实是。他没去过小丑学校吗？我很确定他去过。我很确定他去过。我会说这听起来是对的。好的。嗯，埃德确实会弹班卓琴。事实上，埃德在大学里组建了一个蓝草乐队，叫“孤独三重奏”。埃德会弹班卓琴、吉他和钢琴。这些家伙，他们只是在场景拍摄当天的午餐时间一起练习，以确保这一点。是的。你知道，当他们拍摄它时，一切都很顺利。然后他们到了雷恩必须用德语唱《带我回家，乡村路》的部分。因为必须用德语唱，还要保持曲调，还要在埃德演奏时弹吉他。他有点挣扎。所以兰迪说他们给了他很大的提示卡，他们用拼音写出了歌词的德语部分。他们雇了一位翻译来翻译这首歌。哦，是的。他真的在用德语唱歌词。是的。他们把这些巨大的提示卡放在艾莉肩膀后面，就在镜头外。我想让你知道，如果你去
I mean, listen, I think that if you memorized what I said and you're making pancakes for your kids next time and you just throw that out there, you're going to sound pretty smart.
I'll get it wrong.
They'll call me on it.
You'll be like to write it on your hand.
I know.
Or on a card.
I need a cute card.
Which brings me to.
17分47秒，雷恩就在那一刻。我看到你看提示卡了。你看到他们检查它了吗？是的。我的意思是，那很难。用另一种语言唱一首你熟悉的歌很难，而且这也是一首你刚在吉他上学会的歌。是的。我记得有一首圣诞歌我是在印尼语里学的。Salamat harinat al Salamat haiti natal salamad harinat al Salamadhaanah unbaru 我们祝你圣诞快乐 很好！你们知道我在雅加达长大
Oh.
Such a great scene.
Andy and Dwight in the break room.
Andy's playing banjo.
and Dwight is playing guitar, and they are jamming to Take Me Home Country Road, as Erin looks on, impressed.
Oh, yeah, they're really trying to one up each other in front of her.
And she sings along.
但有时你会用不同的语言学习一首非常西化的歌曲。嗯，你注意到当雷恩用英语唱歌时，他实际上把歌词弄错了一点吗？是的，是的，他翻转了它。他确实翻了。所以真正的歌词是“乡村路，带我回家”。但雷恩唱的是，“带我回家，乡村路”。对。嗯，我只是觉得我们必须听听这个。我们能听听埃德弹班卓琴和雷恩弹吉他吗？带我回家。乡村路。西弗吉尼亚，妈妈山。带我回家。乡村路。在那儿弹。
Mm-hmm.
It's amazing.
We got so much fan mail about this.
Abby Kate wanted to know was any of this improvised because Aaron looks genuinely shocked when they start singing.
And then Jasper D wants to know, does Rain actually play the guitar in real life?
Or did he have to learn it just for this scene?
Well, first of all, this was all planned.
It was all scripted.
走。你必须停下来。听那些家伙演奏多有趣啊？嗯，我知道他们做这件事一定很有趣。我喜欢听它，因为它让我想起了他们在现实生活中的样子。是的。对我来说唯一缺少的是克里德，因为你知道克里德会用他的曼陀林即兴演奏。
In fact, Randy Cordray told us that it cost $22,000 to license the song for this scene.
Also, Rain does play guitar.
He also plays the drums.
And the recorder.
And the recorder, which we know.
And the bassoon.
Oh, my gosh.
He plays a lot of instruments.
我只是喜欢那一刻。我喜欢的另一件事是贾斯汀说，你知道，这真的展示了兄弟情，因为虽然开始时他们试图胜过对方，他们演奏，他们互相盖过，但最终变成了一种兄弟情，相互钦佩俱乐部。艾伦甚至不在那里。她走开了，现在他们只是看着对方，和声并即兴演奏，他们回来了。嗯，当我在研究这一集时，我发现了埃德的一句非常酷的话，他谈到了安迪在剧中的班卓琴演奏。它来自一本电子杂志文章。这就是他说的。他说，我很乐意在任何
He can also juggle. He's a great juggler. He's like a Renaissance fear guy. He is. Didn't he go to clown school?
I'm pretty sure he did. I'm pretty sure he did. I'm going to say that sounds right. Okay. Well, Ed really does play the banjo. In fact, Ed started a bluegrass band in college called the Lonesome Trio. Ed can play banjo guitar and piano. And these guys, they just practiced together at lunch on the day of the scene to get this right. Yeah. You know, when they were filming it, everything was going.
well. And then they got to the part where Rain had to sing, Take Me Home Country Road in
German. And something about having to do it in German and keep the tune and play the guitar
while Ed's playing. He was struggling a little bit. So Randy said they got him really big cue cards
and they wrote out the German part of the lyrics phonetically. They had hired a translator to
translate the song. Oh yeah. He's really singing the lyrics in German. Yeah. They put
these huge cue cards right behind Ellie's shoulder just off camera. And I want you to know if you go to
我能得到的机会演奏我的班卓琴。但没有真正的解释为什么安迪会弹班卓琴。这很有趣也很奇怪，但他是个康涅狄格州的预科生。他是怎么学会弹班卓琴的？这是安迪的许多谜团之一，甚至连我都不完全理解。但我喜欢安迪弹班卓琴，但埃德说得太对了。就像，我从来没想过，安迪怎么会或者为什么会弹班卓琴？是的，这完全说不通。而且他还能拿起西塔琴就弹。你知道，就像他非常有音乐天赋。我理解阿卡贝拉那一面。但这个，像班卓琴，太具体了。确实。嗯，遗憾的是，煎饼早午餐有点泡汤了。
17 minutes, 47 seconds, rain right in that moment. I see you look at the cute card. You see them check it?
Yeah. I mean, that is hard. It's hard to sing a song you know in another language, but also it's a
song you just learned on the guitar. Yeah. I remember one Christmas song I learned in Indonesian.
Salamat harinat al Salamat haiti natal salamad harinat al
Salamadhaanah unbaru
We wish you a merry Christmas
Nice!
You guys know I grew up in Jakarta
是的。除了那个家伙，我想没人来。克里德和梅雷迪思。就是这样。是的。在18分22秒，我们有一个非常悲伤的镜头。迈克尔的，风把纸吹得到处都是。兰迪告诉我，我们架设了巨大的特效风扇来制造这种风，如果所有这些纸都在吹，桌布在风中飘动，会让整件事感觉更悲伤。然后吉恩告诉我，兰德尔，我们的摄影师，花了将近一个小时拍摄纸张吹动
But there were times when you would learn
A very sort of Westernized song in a different language
Well did you notice that when Rain is singing in English
He actually gets the lyric
A little wrong. Yeah, yeah, he flipped it. He did. So the real lyrics are country roads, take me home.
But Rain sings, Take Me Home Country Road. Right. Well, I just thought we had to hear this. Can we hear Ed playing the banjo and Rain playing the guitar?
Take me home. Country Road. West Virginia, Mount Mama. Take me home. Country Road.
Pick it in there.
穿过停车场。就像纸张吹动的悲伤镜头。他说我们从来没用过其中的任何一个。这是一个小时的纸张吹动镜头。是的，那会被放进某个地方的磁带柜里，现在那是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。嗯，现在他们都真的很沮丧。他们回到他们狭小的壁橱办公室，你感觉他们要放弃了。然后电话响了，帕姆接了电话。你猜怎么着？是来自那个家伙的拉塞尔。
Go.
You have to stop.
How fun is it to hear those guys play?
Well, I know they must have had so much fun doing that.
I loved listening to it because it made me just think of them in real life.
Yeah.
The only thing missing for me was Creed,
because you know Creed would have just been jamming on his mandolin.
他想要纸。他确实想要。他下了一个订单，帕姆保证他的满意。她保证了。这是她的保证。帕姆完成了她的第一笔销售。不仅是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的第一笔销售，
I just loved that moment.
One of the things I also loved was Justin said that, you know,
this really showed the bromance because while the beginning they're trying to one up each other
and they're playing and they're playing over each other, it ends up in just a bromance,
mutual admiration club. And Erin's not even there. She walks away and now they're just looking at
each other harmonizing and jamming out and they're back. Well, while I was researching this episode,
I found this really cool quote from Ed where he talked about Andy's banjo playing on the show. It's
from an e-magazine article. And here's what he said. He said, I'm happy to play my banjo at any
而且是她的第一笔销售，他们要把一美元钉在墙上。这是一个巨大的庆祝。帕姆带着轻快的步伐离开了。哦，是的。她跑出去，在停车场给了吉姆一个吻。这是美好的一天。瑞安的妈妈在那里接他。当然。瑞安的妈妈由辛迪·德拉蒙德饰演，实际上有一个场景从剧集开头被剪掉了，她送他去上班并给了他一份袋装午餐。辛迪是一位了不起的演员。她演过很多电视喜剧。她的场景只是因为时间原因被剪掉了。
opportunity I can get. But there's no real explanation why Andy plays the banjo. It's so fun and
weird, but he's a Connecticut preppy guy. How did he pick up a banjo? It's one of Andy's many
mysteries, not all of which I even understand. But I love that Andy plays the banjo, but Ed is so right.
Like, I never thought, how or why does Andy know how to play the banjo?
Yeah, it doesn't clock at all. And also that he could just pick up a sitar and play it.
You know, it's like he's so musically talented. I get the acapella side. But this, like, banjo is so specific.
It is.
Well, sad to say, the pancake brunch was a little bit of a wash.
这真的很不幸，因为我们真的很幸运能让她参加演出。我喜欢那个细节。每次我看到她开着旅行车过来，我就很喜欢。嗯，这一集将以安迪和德怀特结束。他们心情非常好。他们走过厨房。奥斯卡和安吉拉坐在那里。安吉拉翻了一个巨大的白眼。
Yeah.
Other than the one dude, I don't think anyone came. Creed and Meredith. That's it.
Yeah. At 18 minutes, 22 seconds, we have a very sad shot.
of Michael, and the wind is blowing the paper all over.
Randy told me that we set up huge special effects fans to create this wind, that it would
make the whole thing feel even sadder if all these papers were blowing around and the tablecloth
was blowing in the wind.
And then Gene told me that Randall, our cinematographer, spent almost an hour filming paper blowing
还有一个被删除的安吉拉的独白。德怀特和安迪，朋友。我的意思是，这两个人可能有什么共同点？她只是花了一分钟。她就像是，他们可能有什么共同点？然后看着镜头，像有点尴尬。那是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。哦，下周是“激烈竞争”，这恰好是《办公室女士》的第100集。
across the parking lot. Like sad shots of paper blowing. He said we never used any of it. It's an hour
of paper blowing footage. Yes, that would have gone into the closet of tapes somewhere,
which is now Michael Scott Paper Company. Well, now they're all really down in the dumps.
They go back into their tiny closet office and you kind of feel like they're giving up.
And then the phone rings and Pam answers it.
And guess what?
It's Russell from the
guy.
我不敢相信。是的。我不敢相信。今天开车去Earwolf，我在开车时总是给我妈妈打电话，她说，嗯，你们做了多少集了？她说，你们快做完了吗？我说，妈，我们快到100集了。她说，就这些吗？我说，不，我们才走了一半。
He wants paper.
He does.
He places an order and Pam
guarantees his satisfaction.
She guarantees it.
It is her guarantee.
Pam has made her first sale.
Not only the first sale of Michael Scott Paper Company,
走了一半了。好吧，所以我们下周见，为了《办公室女士》的第100集，“激烈竞争”。非常感谢你们的收听。谢谢你们，伙计们。我知道我们刚听到德怀特和安迪一起演奏，但我想在离开这一集时听到埃德的独奏，当我们说再见时。我总是可以听埃德弹那个班卓琴。什么？哦，天哪。你听到了。我太尴尬了。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。
but her first sale,
they're going to tack a dollar up to the wall.
It's a huge celebration.
Pam leaves with a spring in her.
step. Oh yeah. She runs out, gives Jim a kiss in the parking lot. This is an amazing day. Ryan's
mom is there to pick him up. Sure. Ryan's mom was played by Cindy Drummond, and there was actually a scene
that got cut from the very top of the show of her dropping him off at work and giving him a sack lunch.
Cindy is an amazing actress. She's been in a ton of television comedy. Her scenes just got cut for time.
我们的第二杯剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。
it's really unfortunate because we were really lucky to have her on the show.
I love that detail.
Every time I see her pull up in her station wagon, I just love it.
Well, the episode's going to end with Andy and Dwight.
They're just in such a great mood.
They're walking through the kitchen.
Oscar and Angela are sitting there.
Angela does a massive eye roll.
这真的很遗憾，因为我们能请她上节目真的很幸运。我喜欢那个细节。每次看到她开着旅行车过来，我都特别喜欢。嗯，这一集将以安迪和德怀特结束。他们心情非常好。他们走过厨房。奥斯卡和安吉拉坐在那里。安吉拉翻了个大大的白眼。
And there was an Angela talking head that got deleted.
Dwight and Andy, friends.
I mean, what do those two possibly have in common?
She just takes a minute.
And she's like, what could they possibly have a cut?
And then looks at the camera like a little embarrassed.
That was Michael Scott Paper Company.
Oh, and next week is heavy competition, which happens to be Office Ladies' 100th episode.
还有一个被删掉的安吉拉的采访片段。德怀特和安迪，朋友。我是说，这两个人到底有什么共同点？她停顿了一会儿。她说，他们到底有什么共同点？然后有点尴尬地看着镜头。那是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司那一集。哦，下周是“激烈竞争”，正好是《办公室女士》的第100集。
I can't believe it.
Yeah.
Driving into Earwolf today, I always call my mom on my drive, and she said, well, how many have you done?
She was like, are you almost done?
I said, Mom, we're coming up on 100.
She said, is that it?
I said, no, we're halfway.
我简直不敢相信。是的。我不敢相信。今天开车去Earwolf的路上，我总是会在开车时给我妈打电话，她说，你们做了多少集了？她说，你们快做完了吗？我说，妈，我们快到100集了。她说，就这些吗？我说，不，我们才做了一半。
Halfway there.
All right, so we will see you next week for Office Ladies' 100th episode, heavy competition.
Thank you so much for listening.
Thank you guys. And I know we just heard Dwight and Andy playing together, but I want to hear as we leave the episode, Ed Solo, as we say goodbye. I can always listen to Ed play that banjo.
What? Oh my God. You heard that. I'm so embarrassed.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinns.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
才做了一半。好吧，那我们下周见，届时将播出《办公室女士》的第100集，“激烈竞争”。非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢你们。我知道我们刚听了德怀特和安迪一起演奏，但在我们结束这一集时，我想听听艾德的独奏，作为我们的告别。我永远听不够艾德弹班卓琴。什么？天哪。你听到了。我太尴尬了。感谢收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔。
Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent.
Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton.
我们的“第二杯”系列节目由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Ruppertree》。